the honorable
texas republicans ever the bastions of
civil rights and the defense of the
marginalized
have been trying to pass a voter bill
which would guarantee
and protect the rights of all the
marginalized people of texas
but the evil democrats who seek only to
strip the rights away from the poor
and the working class have fled knowing
that they can do nothing to stop
civil rights from reaching the
marginalized people so they uh
uh okay i'm done with that bit but you
get the point the media frames
everything in a specific way what's
really happening is the republicans have
a couple bills they want to pass
that are gonna you know pull back some
of the lacks voting provisions that were
pushed through with covid
the democrats fled they don't want to
give a quorum to the republicans you may
have heard the story but long story
short
fleeing was illegal and the texas house
has voted
to arrest the democrats the moment they
return so there we go
this is it's a fascinating story because
when the republicans in oregon fled for
something about climate change they said
you know we're going to block quorum
we're not going to be here
you can't vote the media across the
board said republicans were destroying
democracy
now what are they saying they're saying
the democrats need national support
so as long as the media is going to play
that game i will play that game right
back the honorable
and noble republicans are trying to
protect the poor marginalized people of
texas
but these evil democrats just want to
hurt and maim and ruin and destroy
we must fight back against the evil
corruption of the democrats and their
vow to destroy democracy yeah okay okay
okay i'm half kidding
half killing because it actually is
happening we got a bunch of crazy
stories today it is it is absolutely
insane today
we got this new report coming out the
navy got woke went broke
a new report says the navy went so woke
they s they stopped prioritizing actual
war
fighting training and now they're not
ready for war as japan is warning the
escalation between the china and the us
over taiwan is getting very serious
no joke now uh elsewhere south africa
70 i think the total amount of debt is
72. regular citizens are shooting at
rioters it is nightmarish
going on so we're going to talk about
all this it's going to be a heck of a
spicy day that's for sure
and we're being joined by the incredible
olivia rondo
writer commentator and wrestler do you
want to introduce yourself
well hello thank you for having me
this is so great um i've been wanting to
come on here for a while i've been
cool with liz on twitter for a long time
we roast each other back and forth so
i think this was a long time coming but
uh yeah so
i write i do my own youtube show which
is small
but i write for manly fee um i've been a
contributor to the daily caller
uh campus reform loan conservative
porter media and the rogue review couple
others
and i'm also a collegiate wrestler which
may provide some insight on some
current events today especially having
to do with the olympics
yep yeah we'll we'll talk about the
olympics and
uh yes the new rules
it's the issue of you know gender and
wrestling and the interesting thing is
there are some instances where
people who are born female and
transition still in some circumstance
choose to compete against females
yet when males uh transition they choose
to compete against females it's like a
one-way street so
we'll talk about that stuff too we also
got ian chillin yeah what up everybody
ian crossland over here i'm looking
forward to talking about
ian's not moving at all something's
wrong with his camera time to fix it up
hold on one second let me tell you from
the distance uh i'm looking forward to
watching these democrats why does this
happen it's a weird thing only within
exact their uh their duty uh to to
perform civil disobedience it's not the
issue the issue is the computer
okay there's get what i'm feeding you
something that happens with the computer
where ian's camera freezes i mean maybe
i'll move seats
yeah you're gonna have to move seats ian
ian has been erased
anyway the democrats of texas are
establishing civil disobedience which is
their duty
um to flee a duty to flee state
they have a duty to represent their
constituents yeah they do tim speaks the
truth
yeah and by fleeing they're not doing
that that's true like even if even if
they were to put in a vote
that was saying no to these provisions
that's the how the process works
my point is saying it's illegal is not
enough to say that it was wrong because
the american revolution was illegal
and i argued that it was right all right
ian's going to put you moving
yeah he's also moving so we're actually
getting this camera the circumstance is
certainly nuanced the issue is how the
media frames everything how they
manipulate the conversation
and if someone wants to stage a
filibuster i've got no no issue with
that for the most part i get it it's
part of the process
but the democrats are the ones who are
saying to get rid of the filibuster then
at the state level are cheering on the
democrats who are filibustering so
what up yeah uh how's your camera like
are you is it is it working it's good
yeah i'll be re-situated oh there we go
oh there's ian
he's
i don't know what's wrong with it's not
the camera it's the computer there's
something about ian's camera
it just freezes on him from a single
frame from the show the night before
which makes no sense
because we concluded the show the night
before it's really weird it randomly
pulls up a frame
from the middle of the show for some
reason freaking weird man yeah
it is weird isn't it i'm an alien yeah
it's true i think ian's doing a purpose
all right we also got lydia pushing
buttons yeah i am technically pushing
buttons in the corner now we've got ian
figured out and i'm excited to have
another lady on the show i always love
having my girls on
i need some female representation over
here we also have a sponsor tonight
that's right ladies and gentlemen
today's sponsor is biotrust keto elevate
go to eatrightandfeelwell.com
you will find the link in the
description below and you can get up to
51
off keto elevate mct oil powder that's
c8 mct
sounds fancy yes it's medium chain
triglycerides what is that
it is the good kind of energy you know
ian's always ragging on sugar
and he's always outraged by the sugar
industry he's laughing over there
because he is
true and this is this is basically like
it's good fat it's it's it's good fat
it's uh
well it's mct oil powder i'll just call
it what it is
and you put in your drinks you put it in
your food it tastes
not like a whole lot i mean it just kind
of blends in it's creamy and delicious
ian's always putting in his coffee i
always like to put in my smoothies
because it kind of makes them
almost like a milkshake it's pretty good
now i'm i'm
pretty physically active i was skating
earlier today so i like to make sure
that we're doing the collagen we're
doing the you know
the good keto energy stuff this stuff
really does make me feel like a million
bucks
so we got some things you got to know if
you go to eat right and feel well.com
you're going to get 51 percent off and a
60-day money-back guarantee
keto elevate provides your body with
only c8 the most ketogenic mct in its
purest form
that means it provides very fast and
effective support for enhanced energy
levels
healthy appetite management enhanced
mental clarity and focus
and athletic performance keto elevate is
very gentle on your stomach five grams
of the highly sought after mctc8 per
scoop
keto elevate is the most advanced mct
powder on the market today and they give
you free shipping on every order that's
cool
for every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor
through their partnership with no kid
hungry.org to date biotrust has provided
over 4.4 million meals to hungry kids
please help biotrust hit their goal of 5
million meals this year
they give you free vip live health and
fitness coaching from biotrust team of
expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order i gotta say every time i read that
i'm like surprised because that that's
like the craziest deal i've ever heard
that's cool
free new e-report the top 14 ketogenic
foods with every order
i'm just going to say this man this
morning i once again have i've been
eating fresh eggs from chicken city
with fresh vegetables i just throwing
them cherry tomatoes are so good
and there's something really amazing
about eating right good good amount of
protein lowering that sugar get some
good fats
exercise take responsibility and eat
right
i know there's a lot a lot of people out
there that really want to just feel
better i'll tell you this man
you feel like a million bucks you start
going for walks you start eating right
so go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com 51
off special shout out to biotrust thanks
so much for being a sponsor the show
guys and don't forget go to timcast.com
become a member we'll have a bonus
segment for the member it's the members
only podcast that goes up around 11 pm
every night
and that's available if you become a
member but when you're a member you can
help support our journalism
we've got a ton of people we just hired
like this is getting crazy
but uh things are going pretty well and
uh the company is taking off we've got
new shows
in the works we've got three new show
ideas we're going to be doing the
the paranormal mystery true crime show
which many of you uh have heard about
already
and then we've got a culture show doing
movie reviews games we got the d
d show in the works it's going to be a
whole lot of fun so again timcast.com
don't forget to like this video
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends okay
now that all the plugs are done let's
talk about the news
this is the big story from nbc 5 dfw
texas house
texas house votes to track down
democrats arrest them when they return
to texas
house democrats can't be arrested until
they return to the state the governor
says so this is the update because
initially governor greg abbott was like
we will arrest them mark my words
now the texas house was like all in
favor of arresting them and they're like
yes
the democrats are going to get arrested
there's a funny thing about all this
it's a filibuster basically apparently
they've they the texas is
texas has already passed the bill anyway
the the voter bills
the media is trying to make it seem like
republicans are trying to strip away the
rights of regular people
the republicans have no real counter to
this because
the mainstream media lies all the time
and conservative media doesn't
oh i can already hear the collective
screams of all the leftists who are hate
watching this show
claiming that all conservative media
does is lie
yeah then why isn't tucker crossing
coming out saying republicans are trying
to pass
voter protection bills to protect the
rights of marginalized people
but the left thinks that they should
take those rights away no he doesn't do
that
the right never does that and that's one
of the reasons the left keeps taking
because they keep putting pressure
they keep doing these propaganda
campaigns well at the very least
republicans say they'll arrest these
democrats who are uh
what are they their fugitives yeah
apparently now
yeah well i mean i guess they're going
to get arrested right does this mean
that they're officially arrested like
does this or not i mean does this mean
like do they have to like
vote on this this declaration that
they're going to arrest them or
they did vote they voted so are they on
the lam now
yes oh wow well that was why gene what's
his name was tweeting about his first
meal delicious fugitive oh it's a caesar
salad oh my gosh
and you get kamala harris and you get
the national level democrats and all of
their cronies in media who love licking
their
feet saying like these are heroes
helping protect the rights of people
let me explain something very very
simple to everybody what the republicans
are doing
actually is to protect the rights of
people who want to vote
what the democrats are doing are
purposefully damaging voter integrity
which confuses and mucks up the system
and makes it very difficult for people's
votes to be counted properly
for the system to work properly there's
no chain of custody on some of these
votes they have curbside voting
universal mail and voting 24 hour voting
not only that it's gonna it's it's
really expensive you got to maintain uh
staffing for these things and security
for these things so what the republicans
are doing is they're trying to pull back
only a little bit
of those special provisions which
effectively means the republicans are
still losing no matter what
this is this is the this is the power of
the democratic party
they win no matter what happens if they
don't get what they're asking for right
now
the republicans only curtail a little
bit
of the of the advanced voting stuff the
democrats got
and if the republicans back down the
democrats get indefinite coveted
special voting access so i don't know
there there are people who are surprised
i'm not a fan of the dem of the
republican party at this point
granted it's texas my mind consistently
goes to the military-industrial complex
the liberal economic order developed
1946.
it's basically of the party of the
warmonger i mean i
thought of those neocons growing up in
the early 2000s and now
it's just accepting that this group like
bill crystal and like
i don't know dick dick cheney's not
really involved with the democratic the
lincoln project
is that what it is no just like those
creepy weirdos friends with raytheon
and now they got their tentacles inside
the brains of the dnc
i mean they always did yeah so it's
funny when people talk about
what the democrats are doing and i'm
like yo the democrats and the
republicans are doing all of that
forever the only thing that changed was
that donald trump
ran full speed and slammed his body into
the front doors and broke him down
and then with trump throwing himself at
the doors and getting in people believed
the republican party somehow like
was better they're not i just saw um
an article that said that the dnc is
proposing that they're going to go
through people's text messages
to look for well that's that's
information i mean that's that's that's
that's absolute disgusting overreach of
power oh that's that's that's beyonce
this is this is this is it the democrats
are like communist authoritarians at
this point but do you really believe
they haven't been doing that this whole
time good point they're just announcing
it now
but no no no they're going to block your
texts like that's something i've
never seen yeah that no that is on a
whole other level unless you live in
cuba blocking your phone call like if
you just couldn't make a phone call
because your last phone call you said
some stuff in it
redacted well definitely we should get
into that but let's talk about what's
going on in texas we got the story from
nbc they say
with only 80 of 150 house members
present tuesday the house lacks the
necessary two-thirds of legislators to
do business
a call of the house motion was called
that compels all members to the house to
appear in the chamber
those who do not appear are subject to
arrest the call of the house was
approved 76-4
with four democrats in the house chamber
voting nay following the vote
the doors to the house chamber were
locked preventing anyone else from
coming or going
wow yeah this is no joke state troopers
in the texas department of safety
may now be appointed to go look for the
missing legislators
at their respective businesses and homes
but they'll be unlikely to find any of
them since they left the state the day
before
texas law enforcement is unlikely to
attract the lawmakers to dc since they
lack jurisdiction the nation's capital
during an interview on fox news monday
night governor greg abbott said
once the democrats who fled the state
return to texas they will be arrested
and brought back to the capitol
they're quitters that's not the way we
do things abbott said in the television
interview
this is fascinating why the democrats
are claiming to get rid of the
filibuster
the filibuster is a problem they say at
the federal level
but this is basically what they're doing
you can charter a plane and flee
you can be you can pick up a fugitive
and flee your actual duty
in texas and i mean this is worse than a
filibuster
it's like miles it's it's a it's it's
yeah it's a hardcore filibuster
for sure like uh so the way the
filibuster basically works
in uh in in the senate if someone says
hey i filibuster then they need 60 votes
to overcome the filibuster i guess they
did that because
they didn't like the idea of someone
standing up and talking for 30 hours
which just shut downs the vote like it
ends the session and so i guess the
democrats tried things like that
you know trying to they they they've
delayed the vote they've skipped out on
the vote
and they keep doing this because they've
lost texas now here's here's the problem
man
you can't function this way we can't how
is texas how is any state how is the
government supposed to function when
people are just like if i don't get what
i want i quit
i'll walk out so is this uh so does this
come from like the uh
oregon republicans doing this to like
fight against whatever it was there like
it was climate change yeah it was like
climate change thing did they set the
precedent here and this is just the
democrats that are carrying it on
no i think this is just a normal tactic
but it's interesting you see this
and and the core issue here is voting
like we're not even talking about policy
anymore
this is literally just i hate you and
you hate me and let's hate each other as
much as possible
if they were like you know we need a
bill that like fixes the road the
democrats are alike but you're not gonna
fix the roads right we argue over policy
like that makes sense
now they're just like the democrats are
like we want no security in our election
we want people to just get
a ballot sent to a random house and if
you disagree you're a racist oh yeah
yeah
so that narrative didn't work if these
people these these democratic
politicians that fled
if they're doing like what their
conscience dictates then i guess they're
doing the right thing for them but
should then they be removed from office
because they can't
functionally participate ethically but
how do you think they actually think
they're doing the right thing i think
it's a virtue signal
i don't think they genuinely believe
that they're saving the day
i i mean let's be real yeah it's it's
it's campaigning
their constituents and their blue areas
are going to be like yay clapping and
cheering for it
nothing's going to change nothing's
going to get done they're what are they
going to do
this is someone saying what do they do
stay out of texas for a year i don't
know
because abbott said we will keep calling
special sessions
until the election we'll keep doing it
so that means the democrats from texas
have to have fled the state and they
can't return
what's a special uh what do you call it
a special what a special session what's
that do
they say election special session so the
way it works is there's no
there's the normal process by which
there's a session of the of the house
like most
states and jurisdictions have this and
if the governor chooses he can convene a
special session and call
back the the state senate and the state
representatives to come in and do their
votes and everything
so a lot of states have that system so
governor greg abbott
the republicans republicans have texas
so he said okay special session it is
and then the democrats were like no and
they ran away now there's no quorum now
they can't hold the vote
so why don't they just treat it as
abstentions
that's a good point and i think they
should i think i think they they i was
saying earlier
they should have they should vote on
this bill right now they should put it
someone should draft it up
if you are absent you know for for uh
at least three sessions in a row you
forfeit your position as a
representative from your district
and you are removed or something like
that yeah you start abstaining
if you maybe maybe you could have
someone come in and vote for you maybe
at the very least send a proxy but then
why are they getting taxpayer money
yeah imagine imagine imagine you're
you're a taxpayer in texas
and these people are like we're getting
paid and they're going to party on
private jets
yeah yeah and their salary should
probably be halted while they're
while they're refusing to do their job
good point yeah look
i'm all for the civil disobedience right
but hey that has consequences
well you get arrested you get fined you
get all that stuff where in the private
sector would you be able to say
i'm just not coming in to work and not
only that i'm not coming until you give
me what you want what i want
it sounds like and you have to still pay
me pay me nowadays
actually a lot of places in the park
okay well i'm old-fashioned i guess
yeah people do this all the time where
they'll be like i've decided that you're
a bigot so i'm not coming to work for
two weeks and the boss goes okay
okay wow whatever you say diversity
training yeah there was uh uh
one of the companies i worked at who i
won't name for this one's a bit specific
there was a woman who threatened
retaliation against anybody
who who told her she had to work and so
apparently she literally didn't know
where
and she got paid a ton of money but what
was the reason
every all the bosses were scared that
they would get a harassment
complaint and they were like but she was
saying they were sexist or
harassing her or what yeah okay like
i don't think it was as overt like she
walked in and said i will say this about
you
but apparently upper management was
scared that they knew this woman would
do it
and it was implied so they were just
like here's your salary you can have
whatever you want what do whatever you
want have a nice day and she's got paid
to do nothing
female privilege and i remember talking
to one staff and and they were like
this person literally doesn't work here
but it's here he just eats food and then
gets paid and then leaves
and then i was like so why why are they
paying this person and they're like
because
she threatens them you know they're
they're scared so that's like implied
blackmail
which apparently is not a crime you can
if you if you're subtle enough about it
you can get away with it no ian it's not
blackmail to say
i will report you for harassment right
you're just doing your job
you're just doing the right thing at
that point yes even if they're not
harassing
can i say that i will report you for
harassment
in parentheses would say if you actually
harassed me but you didn't the line is
very thin and it really just depends on
whether or not
the feds want to go after you or the
authorities whatever in the state
but if you threaten somebody with
accusing them of a crime it could be
extortion or blackmail
but depending on how you frame it then
they can't accuse the person of you know
so the issue is if you're an employee
then in this instance you don't actually
demand anything
you just say i've had it up to here with
this harassment and you look around they
say i'm not going to that person
so you get a person who just anyway the
democrats
this is my problem with the democrats is
the dnc
is obviously corrupt since since i've
seen what they did to bernie sanders in
2016 and
probably so many other things you see
this the dnc stuff
but that doesn't mean that every
democrat is culpable
corrupt or even has bad intentions like
this there's some amazing people that
that happen to be in the democratic
party like obviously tulsi gabbard
i think she was incredible is she still
there though no she ruled
i think i think it mostly does i do
the republican party today is very very
different like trump came in and smashed
through those doors
yeah you had the neocons a lot of those
people fled to the democratic party all
right
but i'll put it this way if like you
know look man i know i know the cartels
murder
tons and tons of people doesn't mean
every cartel member is a bad person
right well that's actually a good point
no no no i don't
think some people are drafted into that
lifestyle
kind of against their will and they
don't want to do the damage and they're
kind of forced to
eventually get out that's a good that's
a good point but let's i was making i
was being facetious a little bit
the democratic party is not a a cult of
well well actually
okay all right okay well the democratic
party is bad but you can always walk
away
you choose to be a democrat you know as
far as i know
democrats aren't going to hunt you down
for being an apostate to the democratic
party
but uh i think the democratic party it's
really fascinating to see this meme
where people say
that the left and the right both view
each other as the problem
i saw someone said the left thinks the
right is abusing its power and we'll do
we'll stop at nothing and the right
thinks the left is doing it and people
need to realize it's like
hold on a minute the people who say that
are the people who are like sitting back
with their feet up watching police
academy on rerun like like
on repeat not really paying attention
what's going on looking at the screen
and seeing liberals and conservatives
fighting they're going
they just think each other are bad well
it's true they do but one side's
objectively right and one side's
objectively wrong and the democrats are
psychopaths
the republicans are do nothings the
democrats are inside what they did to
bernie was basically like made an
apostate out of him
it seemed like in 2016 and he just bent
over and took he just
let them just take it too it's a
disappointment yeah man why didn't he
run independent
i'm gonna be scared for my whole life
i'll be wondering 2016 he could have
went independent and won that race
he just sold out he's just a sellout
that's it how many houses does bernie
sanders have
three i think it's three three three
yeah one that's worth over 1.2 million
or something oh really is that that i
don't know i'm guessing with inflation
maybe
i think he's got like a townhouse in dc
for work he's got his house in vermont
and he's got a summer home he has wife's
parents you write a book
you can be a millionaire too that's
right you write a book so so where did
bernie go when when the democrats
started going crazy
and demanding allegiance and bernie i
remember that photo of bernie in the gym
with that with that really
crappy banner he's like i'm running for
president and then he runs he gets
really really popular because people saw
him as a populist
and he was and then uh he had a meeting
with the dnc and he was like okay
i'll do whatever you say hillary clinton
and then he endorsed her
yeah yeah the democratic machine is
broken there are the neocon republicans
fled to the democrats and now they're
panicking because
the there's like the the gates
to you know it reminds me of that
battling lord of the rings while the
orcs are trying to break into what was
it
yeah yeah that's what it is and uh it's
probably a bad analogy because
in this instance the the orcs are the
are the good guys breaking down the door
but the point is the democrats are in
the in the fortress
and they've they've crossed the bridge
the they've they've broken the doors
down
and now the elites are freaking out
because with a lot of the populist
republicans and trump's popularity they
can't do anything about it
now steve bannon made a good point or no
actually i don't think it was steve
bannon
but uh i can't remember who it was that
populism only goes so far was it was
this therapy
uh maybe no that was daryl it was daryn
yeah yeah populism only gets you so much
you can have all the people on your side
but if you don't have any of the
the elite factions you struggle to get
anything done true
yes yeah when the way that people
kind of cognitively dissonant uh
dissonanted
when when the hillary's emails dropped
i'm obsessed with hillary's emails i i
read a bunch of them john podesta emails
stuff about sidney blumenthal getting us
into war in libya with osprey his
company osprey global solutions was like
gun-running company they basically
coerced
our secretary of state to get us into
war so they could profit
um and people didn't do anything about
it people just sat there and watched
then i realized okay maybe we need
populism maybe we need emotional sway to
get people to do things but like you're
saying if you don't have the
institutions
which we kind of do i mean this is an
institution tim cast is an institution
you know it's
bro we're like we're the rebels yeah
like on
on the ragtag group using makeshift
cargo ships to go up against the death
star yeah this is the millennium
yeah hey i'll take it yeah that's why i
find it so hilarious when you have these
like leftist youtubers
who are just sitting there ragging on
the right all the time
and it's like imagine i i i we we need
we need to parody this maybe
we should do it we should totally get we
should make that comedy show we're
talking about with sheamus
where we could have like thrown the
death star and it's like
empire podcasters making fun of the the
poor people who are fighting back
insulting these these jedi
a bunch of religious fanatics you know
with their order and their force dude
you know and and they think you know
they're fascists they're all fascists
they want to indoctrinate kids
and it's just like a bunch of imperial
guys in the death star and they're
blowing up planets
that's basically what it is that's why i
find it funny when you have these
progressive youtubers
uh i should maybe not necessarily
progressive but some of them
but the really establishment democrat
ones where they're just like haha trump
is bad and the democrats are good that's
right trump orange man bad
no more mean tweets at least trump is
gone
and that reminds me i made this tweet
like maybe a week ago
uh just expressing the cognitive
dissonance that they have
saying like oh at least i didn't vote
for the president
that said that you know i will grab them
by the
p word i'll grab the mother but i voted
for the president that said that if
you don't vote for me you're not black
black people can't use the internet
i mean he disrespects minorities and
black people on a weekly basis he
doesn't know where
he is what was the latest thing kamala
said that poor people can't use facts
has been out of business for years that
just shows how out of touch she
is yeah um and then it was she doesn't
have a smartphone does she i don't think
so
no the one that flew under the radar was
uh maybe
a week or two ago biden was saying well
you know black people don't want to get
the vaccine because they've been
experimented on you know the tuskegee
airmen yes
the airmen the tuskegee
when i say awesome i don't mean like in
a positive way like no i was in awe like
yeah i was just like my job was hanging
over like
did he just call like one of the most
heroic like world war ii pilots
syphilis syphilitic but the other guys
racist
the other guy's racist you had to get
them out it was the bad tweets and
tweets
well you had your choice between
grabbing by the who and trinidad shot at
a pressure
and you know the thing about trump was
like uh
the thing about about trump is like i
mean dude's gonna run again
he's he's off the rails a little bit in
terms of like he's like really out there
and like ah and he's angry he's a
fighter but he's a fighter
and he really does wanna wanna do what
he says he wants to do and you know and
he's not part of the establishment in
the same way
that you know joe biden has always been
a part of the establishment certainly
donald trump is an elite
and i don't know who's on his side but
he went for the american people instead
of the wealthy elites so what it means i
don't so i don't know which elites are
on his side i know he's got the people
right 75 million of them that was truly
crazy to me the people i knew
there was one person who i met at black
lives matter protest
i saw her posting on twitter and i was
like are you voting are you trump
supporter and she was like yep 100 all
the way and she's like sending memes and
stuff i was like wow
a lot of people started waking up to
what was going on and they were like
dude i will take trump over
anything the machine has to offer why
bro the dnc
is crooked yeah i mean the rnc for don't
get me wrong
they just trump's just taken a
sledgehammer to the republican
establishment
he's kind of got them in a chokehold
right now they can't go against him
that's a funny image actually yeah
someone's trying to name that
for sure i really like that some of
donald trump's personal attributes are
kind of spreading like with ron desantis
literally the hand gestures that ron
desantis is using like the whole
little accordion thing he's adopted he's
certainly a king maker now so we'll see
how that
uh forms the gop going forward i kind of
wish he would
help develop another candidate rather
than try and run again because i feel
like they hate him and i mean by they
this establishment media organizations
hate him so much
that they'll they'll really go out of
their way to manipulate
the media so that he doesn't get in like
he's not going to get the tweet again
they'll they'll do this to anybody
though they'll do it to desantis
they'll they'll do it to alan west i'll
do to anybody right
the thing though the thing is why i said
this before that trump shouldn't run and
desantis should
now i don't know if i completely agree
with that anymore that was at the time i
was like here's why i think trump
shouldn't run
as much as the media will lie cheat and
steal regular people
are triggered by trump he's the evil
orange man
they just start convulsing and veins are
bursting at the thought of trump
desantis they're gonna go who uh
the desantis he's he's far right and
they'll go who
you can't trigger someone off desantis
it's not easy because they're gonna
i don't know who that is but donald
trump's been on tv
he's this high profile figure they go
nuts against him and desantis doesn't
have the same statements and tweets
yeah he doesn't have the meanwhile
charisma it's true too desantis is a
calmer
more presentable and easygoing and
younger figure
i mean he's not like mike pence but he's
more like mike pence than like donald
trump
pence is awful calm and reserved yeah
pence was always kind of a do nothing in
my opinion like he just kind of stood
there i met him once he's a nice guy
he seems nice yeah he's nice but like he
was very quiet like he was afraid of
saying the wrong thing
he was quiet possible yeah and now do
you see that cpac did it did a poll
yeah for the pro for the who it was it
was like a straw poll like a primary
scientist one right no no trump got 70
oh
the santa's got 21 guess how much mike
pence got
zero one zero zero yeah it was like zero
point something no
i don't know it just said zero close
enough to zero approaching nothing
yeah dude i i somebody somebody was you
know
chatting they were like tim poole says
he won't go to texas because the libs
are moving there but then he says he
goes to west virginia and won't vote
republican and it's like
yes all of that makes perfect sense well
when you're picking your vp
what what's the point like what what
what do you want out of a vp like why
did obama pick
by they're they they're the president of
the of the senate right i believe
yeah so you want someone i'm a tie
breaker right yeah yeah you want someone
with like uh senatorial experience
is like a is like a big i i think about
you want someone that's more dangerous
to the establishment than you are so
that they won't try and kill you
what that's my thought like if you want
to you want to be like no there's no way
no no
mike pence's establishment yeah
y'all know that quote from like i think
2007 where biden's saying oh well
obama's the first
clean articulate nice gosh well-spoken
african-american he said that about
obama
yeah he's so articulate can we go
deep on biden's racism because this blm
is like a thing right now and biden is
said massively racist stuff over the
last
50
clinton said super predators and i got
hot sauce in my bag oh my god that was
that was weird
i don't understand don't you get it
because black people like hot sauce and
chicken what if she said she had
watermelon in her purse oh that would be
too obvious but like what what's the
difference to be like i got hot sauce
no that was your stereotype clearly no
that was clearly a reference to like
black people putting hot sauce into it
i used to drink frank's red hot my
friend was like i drink
hot sauce i was like oh that's cool i'll
try so i started drinking it was like i
got my grape drink
right oh my gosh it's a lot of salt
though she's ridiculous she might as
well have just said she was like she
carries
she goes she ate fried chicken all the
time
oh did you see what ikea did remember
that no ikea did
juneteenth celebration and they served
watermelon and fried chicken and collard
greens are you kidding me and collard
greens
i don't know it's great i'm not mad at
it
yeah you know you know what really bums
me out though i'm like dude
like fried chicken watermelon collard
greens those are large
seasonings olive oil yeah that kind of
snacks
isn't it crazy that like ikea's like
we're gonna have these things and i'm
like that sounds pretty good
and they're like oh but we're gonna get
rid of it now because it's racist i'm
like come on it's good food it's good
food
who does the funny thing about the
stereotype is like who doesn't like
fried chicken
vegans maybe but they still like it they
just don't eat it yeah
yeah exactly vegan fried chicken oh yeah
actually chicken
like like adam and issues to get the
vegan fried the vegan chicken wings all
the time because like
fried chicken is good you just don't
want to eat the meat i went vegan for
like eight months man when you get a
taste of that meat that vitamin b
oh it's so good it's good but you can
tell these elites you can tell hillary
clinton has never eaten a piece of fried
chicken or any good american fare in her
entire life she eats lizard food or
whatever
whatever flies
she does not have hot sauce in her purse
definitely not no
remember that story about hillary on the
on she was on air force jet of some sort
and then like like high-ranking air
force officers are working on the plane
and she is according to some story i
guess she holds up her wine glass and
goes
yeah like trying to get some like
lieutenant to pour her wine for her and
they're like dude we are
like officers we're not but then they
did it i'm just imagining like her being
on a plane
and then her going and the guy bring up
a big black a big bag of flies and like
ladybugs
and then you're just eating them up
gross no hillary clinton is not a lizard
we're joking we're making fun of her for
being
cold and sociopathic the amygdala is the
lizard part of your brain i believe
everyone has it it seems like in our
evolutionary process we used to be more
just like
hunting and like seeking meat and so we
developed that area
and then over time the rest of the brain
kind of grew around and we developed
thought and more
listening hillary only has the yeah yeah
she over developed amygdala do you ever
see that photo of
hillary clinton in like a regular
person's house and she's just standing
there like
she's looking at the kitchen and this is
what a white refrigerator looks like
wow have you seen that ian no she's like
walking through the hallway and she
stops looking at their kitchen and she
has this look of disgusting and this is
gripping yeah where am i the pores
like that i'm a joke where the judge is
like the only poor people i want to hear
about are the people who tend to my
pores at the spot
that's how i i envisioned hillary
clinton when she's not eating bugs of
course
right uh i forgot we were talking about
because we were making fun of democracy
biden's racism
oh that's right but i felt like it's
like banging on a drum that everyone
already has heard the song
yeah but maybe it's recently he can't
talk about it enough i mean he
he got elected on the fact that he was
the supposed anti-racist president
and he said if you vote well if you
don't vote for me you ain't black
he said that to people literally i love
that meme over there
yeah from from g prime it's the uh it's
the the comic where the black woman's
like i won't vote for you and then bite
in like yeah and he like sucks the black
out of her skin
but you know you know that's why i'm so
late you mentioned that it's like
banging on the drum but it's the same
song everyone's heard but it's kind of
like
fortunate son how like in every single
reference to vietnam you play fortunate
song oh great song
yeah right like yeah we're talking about
vietnam you gotta play fortunate son so
you know it might be the same song over
going to be like joe biden is like
seriously racist
his son is a crackhead like literally
hunter biden is a corrupt crackhead who
is selling the family name
this is who they choose against donald
trump because he said mean words isn't
that hilarious
wow grab her by the hoo-ha yeah
well fbi is not worried about crackhead
honey they're worrying about seizing
legos
that are still in the box unassembled oh
isn't that amazing no i haven't heard
about this so
the first story came out that they found
a fully assembled lego version of the
capitol at some guy's house or something
and then everyone was like all shocked
like oh like like he was
building a diagram of something of the
cat like what's your point about the
legos but then it turns out it was just
a box of lego set
like they went in someone's house and
found a box of legos and we're like ah
wow and the fbi sees it and it's
unassembled
in the box what wha who from who when
did this happen
just recently they were trying to they
were trying to imply that it was like
this criminal mastermind who had this
lego set and he was like using it to
plan something crazy like a movie
it's just a box of legos and like it was
a kid's toy like literally any kid would
have you know be funny it's like
like the feds show up and they go in
ian's room and find like a sketch pad
and he's got a picture of like a
werewolf about to attack santa claus and
they're like oh my god
he's violent what is he planning what
does it mean
and then and then instead of telling
people what the picture was the media
reports like
you know uh podcast co-host has violent
depictions of famous figures being
attacked and
brutalized and then it's like it turns
out it's a werewolf fighting santa claus
yeah like it's just nonsense
yeah but it would just show like the
close-up on the neck with the claw
ripping it open
and they cut out the part where santa
then turns into a werewolf because it
was like
confusing to the general public um i
think that if someone was really going
to plan something they would use like
sketchup
like a like a digital thing i think it
would be like yeah
use legos i don't know if lego is the
scale of the actual
capital building i mean what's more
terrifying is thinking that someone
would have been planning something or
that the fbi would stoop to seizing
legos
yeah this is the media's lego site and
that the media reported it was fully
assembled and they were all like
gasp all these journalists on twitter
these blue checks are like oh
you good a fully constructed lego
you know version of the capital and then
it's like oh it was just a box it was
like
walgreens you know there totally is a
silver lining here though like where we
were super scared of the fbi
like tracking us and being stupid oh
they're clearly incompetent they're
super
confident no nothing to worry about
anymore yeah
remember when the the guy uh the nascar
guy had the garage
oh and like a dozen feds run to the
garage like oh
and they find the rope and like oh oh
this was right after like the jesse
smellet yeah right
wasn't i don't think it wasn't right
after that okay relatively close like
the feds
swoop in and they start investigating a
garage pull up and then they're like oh
it's not a noose it's a
garage pole rope which everybody has and
shouldn't be surprised by wow
but the there's an interesting thing
about you mentioned biden is the
anti-racist candidate
supposedly well no but anti-racist means
pro-racial discrimination
that's ibra max kennedy's ideology oh
right because if you're anti-racist you
and
you believe that all white people
inherently have some type of
thing wrong with them that makes them
hate everybody else if you said about
any other race replace white with any
other group that's racist
so here's what's fascinating though
imagine what kind of person sees a
garage pole rope
and then has like a panic attack and
calls 9-1-1 you have issues
yeah yeah you have issues well and even
if it is
even if it like seriously looked like a
news why would why is your first thought
it's because i'm black
that there's some somebody left this
rope in my garage that just that's
that's the indoctrination man
yeah that's what they're like they're
indoctrinating kids
and people to believe this stuff that if
you there was one where it was like they
said they found a noose at a
construction site remember this one
and it was literally just like it was
like an extension cable hanging down
where someone like tied a knot off yeah
like something totally innocuous and
someone saw a loop and they were like oh
you say it was a hate crime like towards
minorities well the media reports like
noose found at confliction
it's a new symbol a hate symbol the
symbol of the news
it's going to be the adl is going to put
it up on their website they already have
are you serious the symbol of a noose is
a hate sign
yeah already like the swastika okay hand
sign
is now listed by these organizations so
i'm thinking the garage poll rope
probably had like a
like a little loop at the bottom of it
right you could grab and pull
like a handle all new stout so of course
this tiny little thing is a noose
i don't know where we're going man 70 is
it 70 obesity in the united states right
now 60 to 70 percent
i'm just thinking about if we needed to
call up a military if we were really
serious
i'm talking just the in the excellent
of our military right now you're talking
about the fbi which is our internal
police state
uh and and our this has been on my mind
the entire show which is why i'm
blurting it out right now but
we're actually going to get to this we
have a segment oh good let's go for it
well then we got
so we we're supposed to talk about if we
really have an
being racist joe biden is a racist the
most racist president
thank you is he the most racist
president in the last 50 years
yeah well nixon probably i remember i
remember when i talked about that guy in
new york where he said donald trump is
the least racist he's a black dude he's
like
donald trump is the least racist
president we have ever had in this
country
he is but he's still racist and i was
like what does that mean he's like oh
come on man he's like
you know people are racist donald
trump's an old guy so he's probably got
some st you know he's got some
stereotype beliefs you can see the kind
of way he acts but let's be real
he's the least racist president we've
ever had i was like that's actually
an interesting point okay like even if
you think that he's he's racist in some
way
admitting that yeah we had he was like
bro we had presidents who had slaves
and i was like oh that's a good point
actually but he's literally hitler
yeah no i mean the media like these
people live in this fantasy realm where
they're
cowering in the basement it's it's
fascinating i love this when i tweeted
i tweeted that uh that democrat guy
who's like i'm a fugitive
hiding in the airport i tweeted
something like he's a fugitive because
he's trying to
because he illegally blocked a voter
integrity bill to protect the rights of
marginalized people
to vote and then someone responded all
offended some blue check like remember
when you used to be a journalist
and i'm like oh no like over target much
because the way
the democrats and the media works is
that everything is always framed
as if republicans are like goblins going
like
i'm trying to like destroy and burn
everything to the ground so my problem
about talking about the dn the democrats
like their
villains sometimes because i think that
if we if i
indulge in talk like ripping on
democrats then they're going to indulge
in ripping on republicans and then
they're going to indulge in ripping on
democrats
and it's going to propel this but like
those people it's not the people
the people are cool a lot of times but
the system is messed
up you may be a gentleman and a scholar
thank you sir but
so you're like an elf and the orcs are
coming in
and and brutally murdering people and
you're like but we might we must fight
with honor
congratulations i want to know how that
that honor works for you when the ninja
throws the
the the the dirt in your face in the
middle of the fight
oh you think i'm being too honorable i
do like the consistency i would i
wouldn't say like
all democrats or evil or plotting or
anything i would just say politicians
are
i'm not i'm not partisan in that way is
it that's true that the system forces
you to become that way or that people
like that
tend to i think people like that tend to
take advantage of the system so i think
it's a little bit of both
yeah and you know the other thing too is
that people crave conflict
so if you're a politician and you're
just like i don't want to engage in any
bickering i'm sure to get something done
here's the bill my constituents want no
one's gonna care boring no one will know
your name yeah you're not fighting
you're not talking about
i mean thomas massey's feisty he's on
twitter and he's tweeting all this stuff
he's pretty pretty rad he is but he
won't he won't get down into
uh i guess the trenches and actually
play their game
that's good to a certain degree i guess
my thing is
you know the republicans are like now
now
let's not go overboard and condemn the
democrats as evil and the democrats are
literally like so these evil mfers need
to be
like booted from politics and rights
yeah yeah literally
the turn the other cheek method i
thought sometimes i think that that's
like christian that church propaganda to
be like submit
don't don't defend yourself against
aggression and that's all these people
become like slaves
to the church when in reality if someone
hits you in the face uh
you better take evasive action and
figure out how to make that not happen
again that's right otherwise you just
get beaten
but you have right now okay across the
country we had this pandemic
and so then everybody basically said
okay okay let's make voting a bit easier
because the pandemic so we'll do
universal mail in voting
we'll do curbside we'll do 24 hours what
texas was doing
all right now that we have the vaccine
out and the rates are declining and
texas is reopened completely
texas goes so here's what we're going to
do we're not going to remove
all of those provisions we'll remove
some of them and the democrats started
just
foaming at the mouth and screaming and
vomiting all over themselves they're
trying to suppress the vote
so what happens is there's two there's
two principal outcomes now
the republicans give democrats half of
what they want or all of what they want
great bravo or texas yeah i guess so
when i say
i don't want to go to texas because of
all these liberals that are moving there
let me explain something very simple a
lot of people don't get this
joe rogan moves from california to texas
and there's that comic i mentioned
frequently where he's carrying the
liberal policies
suitcase well a lot of people say yeah
but come on you really think joe rogan's
gonna vote in all that stuff
yeah maybe not joe's a smart guy but
what about all the people that get hired
because of the industry he brings to
to austin what about when joe rogan says
i'm moving to austin and then a bunch of
people go like there's going to be new
shows there's going to be
comedy venues there's going to be jobs
and industry and opportunity
so they start moving then you get elon
musk and he's like i'm going to move to
texas because california is oppressive
is elon musk going to vote for these
people maybe he doesn't he's kind of a
weirdo
but what about all of his employees from
california who then have to move to
texas
of course they'll vote for all this
stuff so i'm not i'm not going to go
there
and and and then here's what i explained
when i said i don't necessarily want to
vote for republicans i might
the republicans got me in 2020 we'll see
what happens this time around
the problem is just by virtue of being
republican doesn't guarantee a vote for
me you gotta fight for something
i'm sick and tired of these these
republicans who go in there and just wag
their fingers and literally do nothing
thank you thank you because trump trump
did win me in 2020 that was the first
time i was actually
old enough to vote so i my first vote
ever was for donald trump
um so i've only ever voted for
republicans that one time
but they it's not guaranteed i'm a
registered independent it's not
guaranteed
and especially since we're talking about
texas greg abbott was horrible on the
lockdowns in the beginning he had people
thrown in jail
in the beginning there was this um hair
salon owner shelley luther who was
thrown in jail and then she ended up
running for i think state senate i
believe her state representative
and then greg abbott throws all this
money at her republican establishment
opponent
so you can see the type of people the
type of republicans that are running
texas i mean
they're really no different than the
democrats now i'll give the republicans
one thing
and you first i'll say all the neocons
were just awful i hated that era with
w and cheney and the war and yeah jabong
jeb at least at least he gave us the
memes though right yeah i'm glad he ran
into 2020. yeah we those those memes
will live on forever
i love the meme where he wins the entire
electoral college you ever see that one
more time
but the best one was was in the uk
elections
when they were like it's it's the uk and
then someone made the map of the uk and
it was like tori
and and you know lib dem or whatever and
it was
he wins all of the uk so anyway i
digress
uh look what i will get the republicans
is that
because of the populist takeover of many
republicans they forced the
establishment's hand
kicked out a bunch of the neocons and i
gotta admit
they're as much as i'm not a fan of the
idea of voting against a party
democrats have crossed the line to such
a degree
we are we are at we are at we are at one
of the most dangerous points in american
history
you think i'm exaggerating check out the
store we got from thetimcast.com
alphademo that is to say this website is
not live but you can get a
quick little glimpse of what this
website looks like anyway to the
important news
biden admin is pushing companies to
censor vaccine
misinformation in texts you know the
funniest thing about this story is
so we're getting really close to the
launch of our website
we've got a bunch of uh amazing talent
writers and journalists and
investigators
we're gonna be bringing an independent
fact checker to work off-site and just
do fact checking on our article it's
gonna be fantastic so we're gonna have
an editor
and then we're gonna have a fact checker
and i see this story pop up
from uh from the writing crew and i'm
like there's no way this is real
and i i legit was like when i biden is
trying to censor private text messages
there's no way the government is going
to a private phone company and saying
shut down their private texts all right
i'm like this has got to be
some hyper partisan rage bait trash
what's the real story and i'm like i'm
gonna have to email
people and be like guys guys guys like
we gotta have a better review because
there's no way this is
it's true the story is real i i fact
check this i
i went through it and i was just like i
gotta have a little bit more faith in my
my my writers man manager
because they they wrote this up and it's
legit joe biden
and the dnc are going to phone companies
and telling them to
what what are they what are they saying
um sort through sift out and meet out
misinformation i don't think they should
even have the ability to do that
personally
oh of course they do like of course they
have the ability to do it but at what
point are we just like well they set the
constitution on fire
i don't know man those texts should be
encrypted this is crazy well you got to
use uh
yes signal um and there's probably other
apps i guess
mines has encrypted chat right says
encrypted chat uses the uh the matrix
protocol
telegram look at this quote biden's
allied groups including the democratic
national committee are also planning to
engage
fact checkers more aggressively and work
with sms
carriers to dispel misinformation about
vaccines
that is sent over social media and text
messages
the goal is to ensure that people who
have difficulty getting a vaccination
because of issues like transportation
see those barriers lessened or removed
entirely what does that mean
dispel misinformation yeah
but like look yo we it was like 2016
when they started censoring people and
were like man this sure is like 1984.
then it was like 2017 and luke is like
hey look i made a shirt where it's brave
new world 1984
and uh what was the other one fahrenheit
451 all together and now i'm like it's
been four years since then dude and it's
only gotten worse and now biden's like
come on man i'll censor your text
messages and where's like
the the pitchforks i don't know this is
quiet it's happening quietly
part of the problem i didn't see it on
an msnbc yet maybe maybe this is
not we'll pick it up this is a whole new
level of
beyond you know a big problem with this
that is is
showing its head to me is that a year
ago well even like six months ago
talking about the lab leak hypothesis
was considered misinformation
and would have been censored so right i
don't know what's going to not be
considered misinformation in the future
that's considered misinformation right
now that would cause people to have
their entire
phone history censored or what is i
don't know all right
in the report from politico they gave us
an example charlie kirk
he's the example yeah charlie kirk they
say needs to be censored why
because turning point usa had a tweet
where they said that biden
is i'm paraphrasing is sending out goons
to go door to door to make people who
are not vaccinated to get the vaccine
and they said that's not true that's not
it's not happening
we're just sending out people to go
door-to-door to tell people to get the
vaccine but they can say
no okay so maybe charlie kirk was being
a little
hyperbolic exaggerating a bit make you
get the vaccine
they're not gonna make you do it so you
know charlie pull it back a little bit
but uh
i guess it was a fundraising thing so
obviously the sense of urgency and fear
was included in that
all right but it's only off by like the
degree of
of of magnitude by which charlie
expressed the idea they literally are
sending these people out genseki did say
that they were going to have
have uh vaccine volunteers go
door-to-door yeah
and they're literally now this is the
craziest thing there's a video i think
it's in north carolina
where they go door-to-door knock on the
door and then
say would you like to get the vaccine
and they interviewed one guy was like
hey this is fantastic yes
i gotta say man look if a stranger let
me just ask you a question
let me ask you i'll ask you guys both if
a stranger showed up at your house
knocked on your door
and then pulled out a syringe and said
can i stick this in your arm what would
you say
no no i'd say no i might not say
anything you might just get suplexed
right right there yeah right on my
doorstep but think about how insane that
is
that there are people where a guy shows
up they don't know who this person is
how are they supposed to know and trust
it's a doctor it's a random person
they've never met before like i'm here
to inject you in the arm
listen the craziest thing about this is
there's there's counter indications
there's allergies there's literally
doctors who will tell you
if you can or can't get the vaccine most
people are fine to get it
but you still need to like this strain
change your dorset doesn't know your
your medical
history i i don't want to get too much
into that necessarily because i'll talk
about this i want to talk about the
censorship
but that is happening it is messed up
that's the kind of stuff that they want
to censor they want to
i don't that means dispel you know but
there were a few people who followed up
saying like
let me get this straight like you're
saying they want private phone companies
to like
block these messages yeah this is like
um
it feels like a lot like a hail mary
that
is like this could never hap this could
never get pulled off they could never
pull this off this could never happen
but these kind of things have happened
like i've had that thought of like this
will never happen
the patriot act i was like well they'll
repeal that obviously that thing was
ridiculous by 2005
yeah so this is kind of terrifying you
know the
they can't just come out and do it right
away right
they they announce this right now but
it's not going to be for a little while
until they actually start doing it
because i got to do it one step at a
time very slowly like increment by
increment
eventually people are just not going to
realize your texts just don't appear
anymore and they're going to be like oh
i must
i guess i can't tweet that and then you
know what the left is going to say but
dude it's a private company
wow so so ian what is stopping this from
happening because
i'm i'm with you on this one i'm like
how could this possibly happen but the
more i think about it the more i'm like
why not what's stopping a company from
being like all right whatever you say
what's stopping a phone company like
t-mobile from being like i can go
through our data i mean
they probably already use the data from
phone companies to track people like who
were involved in january 6 right
definitely i would imagine but i think
common carrier rules
i don't know the actual restrictions and
rules but i think that they're not
allowed to like
curate what can and can't be said in a
phone call
or a text technically i think at least
that's the way i believe it was supposed
to have been
right created and protected that's
because they're like a utility right
yeah yeah their utility yeah can't do it
but a private company
well so but well they're there
for youtube isn't there an agreement you
know between
people who use the service and the
company that you know they won't look
through their messages they won't censor
their messages
i think it's the opposite actually you
allow that no i'm pretty sure yeah
everybody
when you like turn on your iphone or
whatever they're like we get access to
your information
because how were they supposed to
transmit the information unless they had
access to it
right there's a lot of people to
understand about these social media
companies where it'll say like
we have the uh it'll say you know in
terms of service we have the right
to host distribute and you know perform
any content you post create or otherwise
display on our website
in perpetuity blah blah and people are
like they're saying they're going to
take all the rights to your content
and what that really means is that
you're saying you can post this on your
website
like people don't understand that in
order for like instagram to actually
show
your image they need to have the
distribution rights on that image
to a certain degree and people like
freak out about that like a
non-exclusive
right yeah otherwise you could be like i
never gave them permission to show that
photo
in this part of the world or whatever i
think um mines
had uh before we went over to the matrix
messaging system it was all encrypted
messaging mines didn't have any of the
messages it would only be the end-to-end
user encryption is what it's called
is that still how it is no well now it's
matrix still end-to-end user encrypted
it's a different system but
a long time ago so i would think these
verizon could be doing that with their
texts
they just have chosen not to they've
opted to to gather the data
oh they've got to let that go to that
you know nsa right right maybe it's time
that we force
uh legalization or well to me this
sounds a little bit like section 230
because why would a company not want to
be able to say oh oh i have no access to
that information i can't even give it to
like a a security organization i can't
give it to the government because they
don't want to be held liable for that
right yeah exactly so why isn't it
easier for them to be like nope don't
have it never had it never saw it
no big deal easier but less profitable
that's probably it
exactly yeah i can see it well we're in
communist america yeah it's fun
the democratic party outright is saying
the democratic democratic national
committee
that they want private text messages
text messages censored
facebook and twitter have already
censored private messages and instagram
but instagram's facebook
i remember i was talking to someone uh
recently on facebook and they blocked
some tweet
or some post and it was really really
weird like
some we were talking about something i
think something with immigration and i
was like here's a story check this out
and it was blocked it was from like a
regular news outlet oh yeah
and it was like cannot display cannot
display there was also a period where
you couldn't tweet out uh i think bit
shoot
yeah you might still might be blocked
i'm not sure
yeah so already as we shift our
communications onto like facebook
messenger instead of text because most
people do a lot of people do
they can already censor what you say
between your own friends i used to think
um
technocracy would be awesome now i'm
starting to think this is technocracy
this is what happens when corporations
technical corporations take over control
the government yeah but like why would i
assume that mark zuckerberg or jack
dorsey or bill gates know how to
actually manage people they don't
they don't they know how to build
software code they know how to well not
bill gates entice people with algorithms
is he not a developer i don't even know
if he's a salesman him and steve jobs
are just business guys
they were really good at manipulating
people and doing the deal i think he did
some early development didn't he
gates i don't want to go too i don't
know no i don't think so yeah i
literally don't think i don't know maybe
this is a technocracy maybe not a
communism maybe this is a technocracy
this is why
it's techno communism bro techno
community yeah yeah it's
commune has been forced and controlled
through the manipulation of
communication technologies communism for
the few at the top
that's how feminism is that's what it is
when has it ever not been that and then
i love it that's not real communism it's
like well every single time you've done
it that's what it's turned into you know
it's funny it's like you tell them two
plus two equals four and they say that's
not real four
it's like bro every time you put these
things together you get four
but it's not real four it's five well
their argument is like
humans are too evil and selfish in
nature for capitalism to be fair but
they're perfect human beings and they
can have angels and saints just
controlling the redistribution of wealth
and that will never happen yeah but it
always happens
yeah yeah i i think the biggest problem
with communism is that we have the wrong
kind of human
i've said this many times like if we had
perfect people this would be great
i think more than a technocracy this is
like so this is almost like ai
because you know humans program the ai
and make it happen now we're just using
humans to try and censor these people
we're using these fact checkers
people like glenn kessler who are just
fantastic
people like politifact we know these
people check facts in a very biased way
so we're like one step closer to ai but
we don't have any kind of there was
there was a famous fact check where
bernie sanders said something like half
of any inner city youth are unemployed
and then donald trump said you know it's
it's a horrible statistic half
of our inner city kids not getting jobs
and then
with bernie sanders politifact is like
mostly true and with trump mostly false
because it's subjective it's an opinion
what is mostly true or false about it
yeah it's like maybe and maybe not it
means the exact same thing
yeah pessimistic optimist we hate trump
so he's mostly wrong we like bernie so
he's mostly right
full half empty isn't it really weird
you know eric weinstein tweeted this he
said you know i swear the country was
completely we had a different complete a
completely different country a few
minutes ago like what happened yeah
yeah no joke like the the chain between
the factions just severed
and now you have the left who are saying
they're just like
when i when i think about the modern
left i see a bunch of people just
standing there
beat red screaming at the top of their
lungs and when i think of the right i
see a bunch of people with their eyes
have closed smug waving american flags
that's like my my im like vision of the
left and the right
right now so you can't have a
conversation with people who are just
standing there screaming at their lungs
do you guys see this viral video of the
woman who's being filmed
and then she drops the floor and starts
screaming and crying i'm like bro
that is auntie no i don't think so that
is millennials that is auntie it says
white woman
and there's a black woman filming her
and then she's like stop doing me
damn she hits the woman and then just
falls straight and starts crying
and screaming and rolling on the ground
weirdly
but the weird thing is nobody around is
like doing anything they're just kind of
like letting this woman
folding stuff twitch on the floor this
is millennials dude
like glad i'm genzi oh yeah well like
but genzie's got
there there i know we're probably gonna
be worse
dude you've got these people who have
never been disciplined and so they grow
up
and all they do it's like that woman who
falls to her knees what did she do that
when she was like seven
and her parents went okay dear
temperature we'll give you whatever you
want now she's like
screaming beat red in the face that's
what antifa is
you can't fail big you can't go back
let me throw a brick at you hey rage
feels good but you gotta get that's why
i do acting and
music because you get it out on in in a
scene on camera and it's entertaining
for people or you get it out in a song
and people
cry but it's like you don't want to do
it in real life rage doesn't feel good
it's like the best yeah yeah exactly
yeah
i don't i don't think rage feels good oh
i love it it strips you of your focus it
puts you in the animal brain
you you lose control yeah and then it's
like you you get nothing done
well if you're performing you're failing
if you're performing when it happens
then well that's that's a production
after the fact
but like to just break down this with
this woman's screaming it is
you are failing you are a failure these
antifa people
when they go out and they're screaming
and just banging their heads and
smashing things
that is them failing at life but the
problem is
you know we can make fun of how dumb
they are but there's a lot of them yeah
going around smashing up stuff screaming
and rolling around on the ground
so like when michael malus says that
these people aren't really dumb so
obviously we're gonna win i'm like
ah there's a lot of them there's a whole
zombie horde out there
and what happened what happens when the
zombie apocalypse
reaches the highest levels of government
check out this story we got from post
millennial
u.s navy in shambles as leaders
prioritize wokeness
over combat readiness this is a report
that was commissioned by congress
and they found in in a couple instances
one
there was on the on the uss bonham
richards i think it's called
it's a 750 million dollar warship
started on fire why
they said the people there weren't
properly trained but i can tell you what
they were properly trained on diversity
they have begun to prioritize diversity
trainings over combat readiness
one person testified that they handed a
cd to someone said here's your combat
training go go do it
but don't forget to finish your
diversity training no joke
so now you have the zombie apocalypse
we're in a zombie apocalypse people
don't realize this
did you think the zombies were gonna be
like walking around mindlessly just
groaning and
and muttering nonsense i hope you did
because that's literally what's
happening with these people that's what
they're doing
and then what happens is they show up
they all start screaming
and the person goes ah and then turns
into one of them
yeah right now now the navy is they're
looking at their phones
and that's turning them into zombies
soon they'll be in the neural net
and then they'll just be like full on
like getting the information they'll be
you'll be looking at you in the eyes but
they'll be thinking about the donald
trump video they're watching in their
mind
yeah it's the borg dude the problem you
know what's funny about the borg and
star trek is that it was efficient
you know it was able to work as a
collective and get the job done
what they don't realize is that who
knows which idea
or or or ideology will become dominant
within the collective
so you right we right now have this this
you know assimilate or die
mentality among the woke left they're
just
cultist ideologues who believe nonsense
and that's why the critical race theory
thing is so weird because
it keeps changing the left wokeness it's
amorphous there's no rules it makes no
sense they're just
insane people they're they they cancel
each other one day wimxin
is the right word the next day it's the
wrong word like oh wymixon is inclusive
the next day oh it's offensive because
trans women are women you can't say
wymixon
there's no rules then one day they say
asian people are white adjacent
stop defending them the next day stop
asian hate they are
just it's just it's just a a zombie
horde
the only thing the collective strives to
do is protect the collective at all
costs
so that means it will not necessarily
provide any meaningful function
to the the the body at large other than
minimize damage to itself so when it
gets into the navy and it's destroying
things and
and things just fall apart that doesn't
matter
the navy failing and these ships falling
apart the u.s
surrendered to iran because of this
that's what the report said
did you know you guys know that 2019 the
u.s surrendered and american soldiers
are on their knees with their hands on
their heads as iranian revolutionary
guard come in
at guns and point them at our soldiers
why because they weren't prepared for
combat and that was under trump
trump didn't realize what was going on
and he should have he had he had people
like mark
milley who is dumb as a box of rocks who
is part of the zombie horde
the whole system is just a flame that's
it it's just it's just
man you know what i'll say the night is
always darkest before the dawn but
here's the way i see it
there is a a an insulated bubble that is
the community that we have and the
people we talk to and the people who
watch this show and the people who share
this show and go to timcast.com become
members
these people are prepared more so paying
attention
active and principled for the most part
they're hate watchers i'm sure
but if the system screws up you know you
look at what michael mal says
about peaceful divorce the dissolution
of the united states
if that were to happen i'm not worried
at all i mean
i got some chickens we got some garden
food we're going we we've got supplies
we've got resources
i'll figure it out i would honestly love
that i love michael malus so yeah he's
he's a smart fella huh
so if look if there was a collapse
the fires rage so hot within the federal
government it just falls apart no real
civil war just
yeah i think everybody's standard of
living would go down i think
i'd be all right with it no i'd be
horrible it'd be horrible no no what i
mean is like
i don't want it to happen you know i
want i want to see america flourish and
be strong and last a thousand
generations because we believe in really
great things but we're being corrupted
from the inside out
so what what would i feel if i woke up
one day and they're like
america's no more i'd be like all right
let's start planting food let's
you know i've got survival guides and
stuff i'll look up proper crop rotation
and
standard farming practices i'll go to
the community up on the mountain and say
guys what do you propose we do shall we
start you know working together and
you know figuring out things on our own
look man
i think at the end i think if you look
at people who live in rural areas
they know how to deal with storms they
know how to deal with trees falling down
in power going out tornadoes
they know how to deal with running out
of toilet paper the people in cities
don't the problem i was studying um
kings in general's youtube channel
highly recommend go there amazing
documentary channel and i was watching a
documentary on the fall the roman
empire last night what happened oh well
firstly it was barbarians attacked
the empire shattered into like six
different countries
um the front the jerk the gauls
basically the people from the north came
down and took
took over all of rome destroyed it and
created the italian empire or the
italian country and then over like 150
years they stripped the rights of the
romans away
slowly so if if we were to do a peaceful
divorce here i could see like yeah
you've got your farm
but then all of a sudden in 30 years or
40 years they come in and take a third
of your property
and and you're at at their at their whim
because they have the weapons they have
the government and then 50 years later
they take another
half of your property and then all of a
sudden they they draft your kids into
slavery
and so if we lose this government
we're at risk of of suffering something
like that i think okay so
right now our government really super
freaking sucks and i would not
be sad to see that go you know i don't
feel like we would miss it all the red
tape would be gone
all the restrictions on these weapons
that we were guaranteed in the
constitution would be gone you'd be able
to you know do it shall not be in france
exactly but apparently it can
be difficult it used to be when they
talked about dissolving the us
people would raise the issue of the
military they're like what'll happen
with the military as far as i'm
concerned the military is
off the table now the navy can't even
defend against iranian soldiers
two years ago are you serious and and
tom cotton is talking about he
has no confidence that the u.s military
will be able to go up against china
china freaking cares about their
military they're taking this seriously
we're not
they can see it mark milley is a
horrible sign of that and i i'm
i feel like a dissolution of the union
would be preferable to this knowledge
china's not worried about the diversity
uh-huh so maybe
they are that's why they banned all the
lgbt accounts on wechat
oh right yeah overnight we don't want
that diversity stuff in china
yeah you guys know about john teeter
tighter or what is it teeter
no that sounds familiar yeah it does
something is a it's probably a hoax
it was an old early internet thing where
this guy claimed to be from the future
oh yeah and there were some really
interesting things about what he was
saying
and a lot of people were like wow the
things this person is saying
sounds like you know they're a really
smart person at the very least someone
was like this has got to be like an mit
engineer who has access to like serious
academic records to pull off this hoax
or a team of people or maybe he was
really a time traveler that's more like
well
it doesn't really matter it's probably a
hoax because i mean you know look what's
what's
the easiest solution someone when the
internet lied hey that happens all the
time
but anyway i bring it up just because uh
when this was going on i think it was
like the late 90s early 2000s
john teeter was posting on forums
claiming that the u.s was going to fall
apart in the
in the like early aughts or whatever and
said like canada would take the northern
midwest areas
the east coast would join europe the
west coast would join china and the
southern states would go to like mexico
or whatever
and uh starting to seem more and more
plausible
isn't it i gotta get off the east coast
yeah but to your point i think that
would be cool if we like balkanized
whatever like i grew up like hunting
fishing shooting i know how to do all
that i could survive i think
wrestling perfect self defense going on
i think i'd be
like a grizzly bear yeah you know one
problem i could
one problem with the balkans is it's
been basically the
the butt of military ravage for like
2 000 years i mean that that area of the
world because it's splinter been
splintered for so long it's just
constantly overrun conquered people are
murdered genocide i mean just tr tragedy
in the balkans so
because they don't have a strong unified
force um
there were periods where they did like
the byzantine empire but it's kind of
sad
you know so i we the power of our states
yeah the federal government is so
important because if we didn't have
coordinated military between states we
would have just been picked apart let's
do this
this roman stuff man it's freaky i know
like the parallels to the roman empire
so how would you so would you support a
very
decentralized federal government that
you know
bare bones it protects your rights it
protects you know our nation's security
but you know the states are kind of
separate do what they want oh yeah i'd
love to build an app where you could
vote on local issues like a tinder style
app where you could be like
hey everyone i'm this is ian crossland i
want to put a fountain on main street
it's going to cost 40 000
vote for this project terrible idea you
go through and then if you like that you
can swipe right add it to your list of
things you want to put your tax dollars
forward
that wouldn't be terrible a terrible
idea i don't think so yeah absolutely
you centralize and localize governance
basically during occupy wall street i
don't know about
i don't know about the app portion of it
during occupy wall street when someone
goes
i think we should we should get bins for
the sanitation crew
then someone was like that's a good idea
i'm going to propose that our bins
are fair trade and then someone was like
yeah but they got to be recycled too and
they went
okay so we all agree fair trade recycled
bins go find them it was ridiculous
the stupidest thing you could find those
they didn't they did they went to
walmart
they were like everyone agreed and then
they went to the store said we can't
find it just by the way
so if i if they were like vote for this
fountain and everyone was like yeah and
they put all this money towards it and
they didn't know how to build the
fountain that's a problem so you know
you would have to like be able to follow
through with your plan i'll tell you
exactly what happened
i've learned the wonders of septic leech
fields only in the past
year because i never had a septic system
before but i can tell you exactly what
will happen
when a bunch of people who know nothing
about anything show up and they go hey
look a big empty field
i propose we build a building on it i
vote everyone goes yay we vote and then
the one
that comes up guys guys guys that's the
leech field for the thousand gallon
septic tank
you can't build on then they go we voted
we passed the resolution
out of our way and then they build on a
septic leech field and
then they die although i don't mind
that's why you have governors
you have governors and mayors to to like
stop stupid behavior you know
but so you mean elected representatives
yeah you still have them
but but rather than like rely on an
external person to come build that
building for you you could
like locally here's what would happen
dude people would vote for the building
then someone would say
look that's a leech field we have a
regulation barring the building of that
and someone go i propose we get rid of
that regulation
ah they also they'll vote to get rid of
it because people want to make money
and it's it's it's it's right it's not
easy to govern
democracy does not work if a bunch of
people voted for the the building on the
leech field and it was all these people
voted for it so it was ready to go
and then all of a sudden they found out
it can't happen it would be removed from
your list by who
by
at any point the mayor could be like i
do not want this civil rights bill
deleted
i'm the smart one well if it violated
some sort of standard yeah
what standard by who who sets the
standard the leech field who sets the
standard
well the people dude through the
governance right so when the mayor says
you can't but unleash field like i said
they'll go we vote to say you can
so the mayor is pointless at that point
but saying direct democracy over
rule things i'm just saying a way for us
to pool funds locally
yeah do you ever look at a uh a map of
a topographical map of manhattan you can
actually see in the skyscrapers where
the bedrock is it's fascinating what do
you mean
they can only build the skyscrapers on
bedrock wow they can't build it on the
dirt it sinks that's why there's a lot
of cities where you're like i wonder why
i don't build skyscrapers here brought
to swamp
like dc is a swamp yeah you know what i
mean like literally swamp
so it's hard to build massive buildings
because they sink
manhattan is a big rock so that they can
build and they can carve holes and do
subways it's actually
you know fairly easy but there's like a
line because there are some areas that
are you know dirt and mud and stuff
regular people don't know these things
so they're like i propose we build a
building sideways
and then you're like that you can't we
shouldn't do that i'm gonna do it anyway
and everyone's like yeah sideways
building woohoo
and then construction crew goes hey
we're getting paids
gonna go builds the sidesways building
and then they start building it and then
they just
no no you definitely need checks and
balances but i can't stand that like
people in upper echelons of government
are deciding what gets built where and i
don't have like
an opportunity to input yeah like a
convenient way to input
what if and and just bear with me or
what if uh i pulled up on my app
and i wrote let's bomb cuba and then
swiped right and your hypothetical
government that's not a location
and everyone said yes we vote to bomb
cuba like this story from newsweek yes
you enjoy my segway there bombing cuba
an option that needs to be discussed
says miami mayor
no right get that guy out of there and
we we don't want to bomb cuba
they just discuss i mean but chance your
mouth
i i don't i don't think we should
discuss bombing cuba seabird
like air strikes air strikes on cuba
what's this crazy person that's right
look
look people are protesting in cuba and
they're yelling i think they're yelling
what libertas libertad libertad
liberty freedom and down with
dictatorship and things like that
and then you know the mainstream media
is like people are upset about covert in
cuba
anti-government slogans the pro the
pro-communist people
and uh cuba the cuban authorities have
been i guess locking
people up they blocked the internet we
got this from voa cuban authorities
block access to the internet response to
protests
my favorite aspect of the story is when
brian selter of cnn tweeted out this
quote where he's like
restricting access to the internet is a
move of dictators and i'm like what does
that say about
joe biden and jack dorsey and facebook
and you
because he's the one who's gone on and
said don't listen to fox news and
you know been a defender of banning and
regulating speech on these platforms
so what does it say about all these
people but yeah anyway look people of
cuba they're fighting back
i don't think we should go bombing them
though but uh bomb who why
what what is this the communists bro who
are the who are those
what does that even mean the president
of cuba the communist party of cuba what
do you mean so like this guy wants to
bomb
the the sitting government of cuba
localized in one communist building or
how do you go about that
seems tricky yeah the us is like we're
going to surrender and convene a meeting
of all the great communist party leaders
in this one building right here
yeah this time they're like okay and
then you
yeah look at this this is funny uh in an
interview on fox with fox news
this is uh francis suarez noted a brief
history of u.s involvement in
overturning foreign leaders
his history mentioned the us airstrikes
in kosovo during
the 1999 humanitarian crisis are you
suggesting air strikes in cuba
fox news anchor martha mccallum asked
what what i'm suggesting is that is that
option is one
that has to be explored and cannot be
just simply discarded as an option that
is not on the table
suarez answered and there's a variety of
ways the military can do it
wow please expand on those ways yeah
seriously
i gotta say though i'm curious cause
like a lot of people in miami
are cuban and are protesting in support
of the cubans
but i i think an airstrike on cuba would
kill civilians
you know you get those little drones
that are explosive and you fly them
through windows
that's crazy they have those that's the
that's the next i warned about that
back in the day because we were working
on i was working on this university
drone program
i actually went and chose the first
drone test site for the for the for the
government program on like how to do the
research and i was like
before it started i was talking to a
bunch of like government people in
academics because i had done this drone
research
and they were like we need to get a
better understanding of what drones mean
and i was like
the drone that we've seen can carry like
a kilogram
what happens if that drone carries an
explosive how will you stop it
and they were just like stone-faced like
yeah
it's here now the technology exists
and they were just like uh maybe we
should regulate these things dude
they're gonna make
have you heard of smart dust they're
gonna make drones that are so small
smart dust is like yeah ben stewart was
talking about it it's in the roads in
denver
apparently it's like they're mini
sensors like dust sensors that are as
small as dust
but they're gonna make drones that size
they can like fly into your inner ear
into your brain yeah i don't know about
all that stuff yeah it's
too crazy for reality i know they do
have very small
drones that can fly like insects there
was a kickstarter
there was there's a kickstarter for them
once they're really really cool the
remote control they just
they just flashed really weakly in
flight what was that that
crazy drone movie it was like 10 minutes
long uh
murder drones or something it was called
do you guys know what i'm talking about
oh you've got to see it if you haven't
youtube yeah and it's this like
dystopian
this this guy's building drones like
amazon or whatever he's like we're gonna
transport all you we have drones
everywhere to transport
and then the drones go haywire and they
start patrolling the city all day every
day drones flying above murdering
shooting at anyone so people are
basically running from building to
building
a black mirror and trying to live yeah
with the bees yeah no not the bees the
dog ones
it's similar man yeah the dogs were
running around hunting people down the
robot dogs
they had an episode where there were
these bee drones that would like burrow
into your bees die yeah yeah yeah
yeah yep bees die so they replaced
pollen bees with
robo bees and the robo bees went nuts i
don't know what that has to do with
bombing cuba though
it's the 21st century bombs as well tiny
little drone bombs
yeah dude i wonder if they have like
antimatter bombs yet
um yeah i was reading about anti-matter
bombs because like
when antimatter comes into contact with
matter it has a 100 energy release
so it's extremely expensive to produce
and contain antimatter
because if it comes into contact with
matter you know boom
they put it in a magnetic ring okay yeah
so it's it's contained
spinning around really fast and so to
make a device that could utilize that
that'd be crazy too low iq for this
conversation
really really powerful explosives yeah
put it mildly boom boom yeah yeah really
expensive to produce at this point like
i'm talking trillions
like a proton and a negatron i i think i
think i think
megatrons aren't real yet but we got a
coin negatron
and uh electrons and positrons the
positrons real but the proton and the
negatron
what is a negative proton called i don't
know it's true
right antiproton okay yeah megatron's
better cooler yeah
way cooler positive yeah but a proton is
that a positron
positrons an anti-electron is a positive
oh right right right right
okay proton i don't know megatron dude
so this is not very
political anymore no this is a great
conversation though i want to talk about
we might go into this more since you're
a wrestler and we talked about
like uh trans women in wrestling we
might go into this yeah we'll talk about
that
it's it's funny because like we end up
talking about a lot of that stuff in the
in the members only podcast because
that's stuff youtube bans you for
yeah we'll go deep youtube right just
like
like the segment we did yesterday with
with colonel uh west
like i was i was i was mad like this is
dark
dark stuff what's happening people were
commenting that too they were like this
is a dark episode
i know it was horrifying what they're
doing people watch that but we'll
we will talk about that i suppose for
now we're mostly focused on like
whether or not we blow up cuba yeah so
and uh we're just discussing it yeah
there's a lot of people right now i i i
imagine people like john bolton are
saying they're like
stocks raytheon
no i don't know raytheon got woke did
you guys see that no yeah yeah raytheon
got woken up i don't think they did like
a pride month
thing oh no they had like a white
privilege training thing even better
i'm i'm kind of i'm kind of okay with
that like i
i think about these companies or like
the navy getting woke and i'm like no no
no no this is bad this is bad you know
get go broke and then the federal
reserve gets woke and i'm like
maybe i'm okay with this and then like
raytheon i'm like
oh do i support this now like it's
it's gutting these these institutions
from the inside out and they're being
disintegrated
no because it's it's fire you know what
i mean and you might have like
schadenfreude when you're watching
fire engulf like some you know enemy or
something
but that's that fire spreads it's so fun
to be an accelerationist sometimes and
just watch it burn
from afar sometimes but it's it's it's
you don't even need to be in
acceleration
anymore i mean the stuff that the the
navy
look at those videos of the us soldiers
surrendering to iran and if that doesn't
make your blood boil what was that uh
that whole process i didn't see that
there were a couple of boats
they got surrounded the u.s surrendered
they were like in in iranian waters or
something i don't i don't remember the
exact details
but people heard about that the us
surrendered a couple small ships and u.s
soldiers are on their knees their hands
on their heads
swam to the soldiers oh they got
released yeah they got they got released
by the iranian revolutionary guard
but uh it's amazing when we prioritize
wokeness
our own navy our army so what you're
saying is that we could technically bomb
cuba but we're not going to be able to
because we're
super woke now in the military it's
completely inefficient wow
that's the only reason we don't bomb
cuba we have a lot of other issues
i'm just imagining that plane with the
rainbow flag on it and black lives
matter in the front
dropping rainbow bombs and the little
middle eastern children are like yeah
oh diversity yeah well they're cubans
now so
right now yeah still brown you could
probably put like little prism shards
in the explosives so that when it blows
up it's not red it just looks like a
rainbow
glitter yeah we've added 1 000 pounds of
glitter to our ordinance
i think this guy this cute this uh
floridian guys
is espousing rhetoric political rhetoric
of
nothing's off the table you know they
say this stupid stuff like nukes are not
off the table
in regards to cuba my neighbor is is
keeping me up at 2am with his rooster
nukes are not off the table
but because they're not that's the point
of the military is you don't want to
take that stuff up but then why wouldn't
you just come out and be like
no nukes are off the table but secretly
they're not off the table like that's
better
nukes are never off the table bombs are
never off the table but i don't i don't
see what's to gain by actually
intervening with cuba
i don't like communism you know but i
just think the us is a
i mean it's probably good for the
military industrial complex because
they'll be like oh we can screw up the
united states and then
create another massive crisis where
we'll get funding from the government
forever yeah let's do it
c's cube install a central bank there no
they'd probably just blow up half of it
and then try
nation building for 20 years yeah
yeah although cubo's really cuba is
really close to the u.s so
make it a state it's not going to be the
same as oh man could you imagine
we got guatana bay already yeah cuba the
51st state puerto rico doesn't
we have an american military base in
cuba yeah they hate us they're like get
out of here that's so weird
there's mcdonald's there they um the
spanish what was it the spanish-american
war
1898 i think it was was when the spanish
empire
was controlling cuba and america was
like we're going to liberate cuba so
they did
and then cuba was free and then castro
came in and took control so if we were
going to liberate it again
what do we do after that because wasn't
it like him and shay
and and castro was like hey check this
out i'm going to enslave all these
people and she was like ah you won't do
it man just going to bed he's like yeah
i'll do it then he did it there was
smoke he smoked a cigar
yeah probably and then shay was like you
know and then shay was like yo
guess who i don't like and then fidel
castro laughed and he was like jay you
don't like brown people
and then shay was like that's right shay
was like oh you're supposed to
be super racist yeah super homophobic um
yeah i've heard that i've heard that a
lot yeah
is communist tend to be like was it marx
i think che guevara was too he was
that's what i mean yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
they're all about markets yeah mark's
they're pretty sure mark's super racist
yeah yeah yeah that's why they didn't
like the theme yeah
yeah even the critical race theorists
are racist so there's like a thing about
these leftists
they just really like being racist i
think they're projecting like especially
the white
liberals who are like oh white people
are racist you have to atone for your
racism you have to admit to your racism
and then everyone's looking like they're
a weirdo like what are you talking about
i'm not a racist
and they're like yes you are because i
am and i feel bad about it
and i have to apologize for like no you
know go to therapy
don't don't project on everybody else
not all white people are racist i do
love it they're like yes you are because
i am it's like that
i okay thank you for admitting that but
i'm going to
leave now these are my racist glasses
i see racism everywhere that's if you're
if you're racist
that lens is gonna it's gonna make you
see it when you look outside
so at a certain point are we gonna be
like um tony shalhoub and galaxy quest
just laughing at the absurdity about to
be about about how we're about to blow
up or something
you guys no not me man have you seen
galaxy quest
uh part of it you what
i thought it was gonna be awesome i was
like oh it's gonna be the greatest genre
sci-fi one of the greatest genres it's
got sigourney weaver ted uh tim allen
it's scott tony shalhoub tony schloop
and then what's the guy who played snape
oh it's alan rickman sam rockwell
rockwell's rocket
that's a great cast and the movie is
fantastic but anyway they end up in the
spaceship and they're just actors
and so they're like freaking out but
tony schloop's character is like
all right man i guess like whatever
laughter like they're about to get blown
up and he's just laughing like yeah
laugh or cry man
like at a certain point i just keep my
feet back and back bro i got chickens
we got space we got tomatoes bro we
harvested the carrots we got like
10 pounds of carrots dude i can't even
eat all these am i supposed to do with
carrots
i don't even know i grew that many it's
gonna be good carrots too it goes good
we'll make juice cake we got jalapenos i
was having
last night i don't know how you guys
feel i was having kind of a a nihilistic
night last night do you guys go through
this where kind of like you're saying
just laugh at all the chaos like well
let's just get what i can out of this
before it's
that's all over that's what our leaders
have been doing for the past 20 years
for probably thousands well you're right
now america was functioning
we rallied against the nazis in world
war ii we had
drive during all the horrible
interventions we did right
with vietnam in korea there was still
this american elite being like we're
gonna go to war cause we're better than
you
now it's just like oh the system's broke
i'm going to steal as much silverware as
possible before the house burns down
now we talked about before it's like the
titanic's going down and they're running
room to room grabbing stuff before they
jump on the life raft for everybody else
i know we can fix the system like we
could build a software
like a you know decentralized powered
system that's powered by like vacuum
energy or like fusion energy
localized that where people can
communicate uncensored
but i don't know if the human um
consciousness is is able to do it like
i don't know if if humans are just too
too busted as an animal that we can't
function you know sociologically at
scale
i wonder about that i know we can build
the technology
gotta get that neural link bro gotta
integrate resistance is futile that's
right
what's that gonna do though maybe not
hear your crazy phone on the board man
no because everybody will just be the
board will it make the craziest person
make everyone else crazy or will make
the calmest person make everyone else
everyone will get crazy that's what i
was explaining right in star trek
the borg was working in unison towards
towards a goal of assimilating more
technology and expanding and whatever
but the reality is if you assimilate if
you've got 10 people and six of them are
psychotic leftists and you assimilate
everybody
the collective just becomes
psychotically left it won't function
properly it'll just spaz out and accuse
everyone of racism and then collapse
if you had like nine crazy racists and
then a tenth like really calm zen
buddha master joined would it make the
other nine very calm
or would it turn the buddha master
racist the buddha master wouldn't
necessarily become racist
but if they all function in line with
the collective they would all move
towards
the crazy racism so the buddha master
would be like oh i'm having crazy
thoughts but he keeps
dispensing his thoughts having no
thought and then eventually the crazy
people start to have less and less
thoughts that's how the borg works
how do you know because i watch star
trek you've never been in the fork tim
they they look at picard when he became
the borg he they talk all about it seven
of nine talks about it but i'm saying
they they lose their their control their
voice becomes one with the collective
and they all function towards the
collective goal
of course there was the borg queen who
secretly was manipulating the collective
that's
that's communism i mean that's exactly
what you can expect to happen so if
there was no queen
i wonder i wonder if you would as a
strong mind be able to
warp the collective to bend to your will
so to speak for the for the good of
humanity well i think there's like a
i think there's something like that in
marvel with like dr doom
i think the guy's got an iron will he's
like a villain but he's my favorite he's
almost like a hero
almost like a hero yeah what was he used
to be part of the fan he was with them
on the ship the fantastic four when they
went into space and then he got
what power did he what yeah he got like
uh i don't know what like lightning
power or something
and like he wants to not destroy
humanity what is his goal
save humanity he wants to save humanity
he's a communist dictator basically he's
an authoritarian dictator who thinks
that
humanity will only survive if he is the
one who is in charge
yeah and there's like this famous comic
where he's like confronted by this great
panther spirit or whatever
and then he's like i have seen a
thousand futures or whatever and
each and every one humanity is destroyed
the only future i've seen where humanity
survives is when i'm in charge
and then like the spirit finds that he's
like pure of heart
like he actually actually means it i
like him
let's read some super chats if you
haven't already smash that like button
please
and subscribe to this channel share the
show with your friends hit that
notification bell which apparently
doesn't do anything anyway
because it helps i guess uh sure and go
to timcast.com become a member we're
gonna have a bonus members only podcast
coming up
just after the show around 11 or so p.m
so make sure you check that out and
let's read some of these super chats
all right let's see all right what is
this
gemcast dcl says is tim 18 us code 241
conspiracy against rights
i think this is a good attack vector for
the free speech or any other rights
argument you should look into it
i will look into it mediocre fisherman
says if you can pick two political
figures to run in 2024 who would it be
well i don't know who dave smith's vp is
going to be
but i am really really looking forward
to a michael malus press secretary for
the libertarian party
that is going to be the greatest thing
ever
i mean it would just be like wow that'd
be supreme
i would vote for that so fast i would
love to just go back to like 14 year old
tim and like sit down and be like listen
in 2024 this guy named michael malus
will be the press secretary for a
libertarian candidate
and it's going to be glorious and then
just like
show like a clip of michael mouse and
the things he says and then get my
younger self all excited for just the
shenanigans
the epic trolling of the establishment
machine i had
one single interaction with michael
malus it was so hilarious it was so
strange
i was at a cpac after party last year
like literally the last night before
kovid like shut everything down
and he shows up fashionably late and i i
knew who he was but like
it like he definitely looked familiar to
me out and someone was like oh that's
michael mouse i was like oh look i
definitely follow that guy on twitter
and he comes up to me and he's like i
love your hair is that racist to say
i don't care i don't care i love your
hair and i have this long
twist and i was like no it's not racist
thank you and that was it
[Laughter]
all right uh we got uh colonel jack
o'neal here who's uh taking his break
from his stargate missions
and he says ian i love you but sometimes
you say something so insane i want to
slap you until your eyeballs switch
places
you probably feel better if you were
here i'll try and like air out weird
ideas and thoughts and sometimes they
come out incomplete
i maybe is a little frustrating to
listen to i could try and i can try and
read that as richard dean anderson
ian i love you but sometimes you say
something so insane i want to slap you
until your eyeballs are musically in the
background surging right now is he
saying it dude
they do like three episodes of sg-1
every day now
it was two episodes at first now it's
three and i'm like i can't keep up with
this
i'm jumping episodes i gotta keep track
of what's going on it's a good show by
the way i love sg1 it's fantastic
all right silver kestrel says not
surprised with the navy getting woke
this happens during the spanish civil
this happened during the spanish civil
war of the 1930s their navy
overwhelmingly broke for the leftist
republican forces
wow could you imagine that what if
if the navy becomes overwhelmingly woke
and then they just like basically
defect that's going to happen to some
degree what happened
with that i don't know something just
happened in the past but what's
happening now is unique
you know it's not the same there's
similarities but we don't know what's
going to happen
all right lamb says i want to shout out
james lindsay's new discourses channel
podcast
the near four-hour episode on hegel
wokeness and the
dialectical faith of leftism is
brilliant and very eye-opening
absolutely james james lindsey is a
smart fella
all right let's see tanner hein says
have you seen gavin newsom's campaign
ads claiming the same republicans who
refuse to accept the election results
are back again to smear him and waste
taxpayer money on recalling him
ah projection yeah it's funny because
it's not just republicans that want to
recall newsome
it's a lot of people who are democrats a
lot of democrats are fleeing the state
because of that right
yeah well all right let's see
james could says texan here some
democrats just simply don't care and run
to daddy biden when it's rough
you were elected do your job servant
leadership needed
yeah the people and the democrats in
texas are supposed to be like oh i'm
here to vote for my people and
if we don't win because we're in the
minority position like at a certain
point you recognize what democracy
a democratic republic is supposed to be
or constitutional republic with
democratic institutions
to put it more specifically okay
keith mccracken says ian stop with your
powerful thought energy
you're disturbing the camera keith now
i got to stress this right so ian's
camera froze
from a random frame from last night
which is weird
because the show ends like that's the
second time it's happened
yeah more than that yeah oh really yeah
usually we just restart opps
what is yeah usually we catch it yeah
but it's weird that it's an image of you
from last night's show but the show went
on like normal and then ends
then like it just randomly pulls up this
image and freezes it there dude
that picture do you think people are
capable of like inter interacting with
electricity
yeah you're too powerful i think that's
it have you ever had that where you like
you shut
a light just like well it's never
happened to me but clearly you're gifted
it's not intentional i think it's a
psychedelic do you think uh
do you think we'll get copyright strike
we'll get a copyright strike if i
if i play music on my phone it depends
on the song i guess
yeah cause i was going to play the song
because uh because somebody
oh i just got an iphone and it's got
this thing but somebody was like uh
jimmy kinto says will we get more songs
like will of the people
yes because i got this epic new app
can you hear that there goes yeah
if you sing it oh actually i think that
song's public domain how's the right oh
yeah
yeah let me look yeah i think that's i
think that's public domain
it looks like a really old folk song i
like that song
yeah but uh we're we're gonna get more
songs um we're we're trying to hire a
composer like
we need somebody whose job it will be to
just sit around all day making
beats and tracks and music kind of like
ambient hip hop
rock indie style just a mix because we
need to use the music for
our shows for the podcasts and then we
can take some of those songs and turn
them into full songs so we
literally need someone who who like just
sits around making music all day and we
can hire them and have them just sit in
a room and make music all day i've been
watching a lot of beatles lately
and man something that music desperately
needs right now is that
[Music]
la la
but what we need is like a solid uh
melody
through-line story like what you're
saying with will the people but with
that like
la la yeah in the background like we
need more of that doo-wop
in rock that's what made the beatles
great
all right let's see eli says ed calderon
worked in the fields of
counter-narcotics
organized crime investigation and public
safety in the northern border region of
mexico
a u.s citizen now and can definitely
confirm what alan west said please get
him on if you can love the show oh ed's
manifesto
he's great follow him on instagram yeah
rick
resler says donation for tim's wardrobe
sunglasses 100
thumbs up and crying laughing face what
what's wrong with my wardrobe i have
a hat a shirt a shirt and a pants
clothes yeah
i don't know what you can't even tell
kind of pants i'm wearing one of these
one night tim's gonna wear the craziest
outfit
well i do have the the the the black
shirt and the gray shirt but i don't
really wear that that much you need like
a crown
and like just a crazy flamboyant robe
with
purple style
like a friday night or something
all right let's see uh some people are
asking if i'm familiar with robert
barnes and viva phrase show i am
familiar with their show absolutely all
right connor
o'brien says uh let's see
okay maybe i can't read that one sorry
connor i don't i don't know what's about
but youtube's very sensorius so i'll
have to walk away from that one
um eric a says have you been following
china's actions in south america they
built a space base in argentina
china increasing ties there is worrying
argentina is part of the lithium
triangle
where over 50 percent of mindable
lithium is yes china was trying to build
something called the nicaraguan canal
you know about the story no panama canal
very powerful because we have a shipping
lane that goes through the americas
so china was like we'll just build one
through nicaragua how much will that
cost can we do it yes
it would have destroyed this massive
freshwater aquifer
and it was going to just cause a lot of
people to have no water
and the project got scrapped but it was
going to cut through nicaragua which is
like
substantially longer than panama isn't
it
bigger sure right as an f you as a
nephew of the panama canal
yup china is like they're they're
they're not they're not backing down man
i mean
you know what they're doing is craving
crazy
all right john marafa says two things
one texas dams have done this before
fleeing to oklahoma some years ago too
when these guys fly back from dc i hope
their plane drops out of the sky
no no we don't want that we want their
plane to land safely because you want to
see a perp walk
this is the important thing about
justice you need to have them
in a court of law pay the penalty so
that everybody knows
and sees it's legitimate and they've
paid their like
they're being held accountable through a
legitimate process that's why with the
nuremberg trials
we said we're gonna put these people
down we're gonna we're gonna show
everybody the evidence and we're gonna
prove it in a court
you gotta make sure that happens these
people they gotta get arrested they land
they broke the law they get arrested
there you go all right
jmac says some elites are fighting back
there was some businessman who helped
fund south dakota's national guard being
sent to help with border security
hell i give super chats to those i feel
with a good platform
people are fighting money with money
anyways keep it the good work
cast team thank you very much yeah we
need uh
people to donate to you know republicans
in cities
i mean imagine this you get someone like
aoc who's got a powerful media platform
but she didn't when she started
when she ran for the first time there
was no actual republican candidate i
mean there like literally was but like
not really
apparently the dude didn't even have a
website how were you suppo
they're like oh we can't win there
because it's too democratic republicans
give up you didn't even try dude
did not even try democrats certainly try
to get young people in
red areas certainly republicans just
give up though
yeah that's the reality oliver moreland
says we just protested our school board
in rochester
mn for these far-left teachings we had
some good speakers and i got footage
that i'll edit tonight
we all need to rise together against
this insanity that's for sure
a muzed says to the lord of the rings
analog the elites view the people aka
the rebel as the orcs yeah who is the
who's the eye of sauron then
i don't know if the rabble the dave
reuben no
i don't think first it would be like a
populist
uh it'd be donald trump right trump yeah
actually yeah
the eye of trump all right let's see
trd has a great super chat and i can't
read it because
uh well because i can't read it i'll get
youtube says you can't say these things
so i can appreciate that you send the
super chat in but
i can't read what it says but he does
say salty army is legion and the salt
must flow that part i can read the rest
i can
smokes says michael malus anarchist
hamburg handbook inspired me to break
the first rule of super chat
in making a guest suggestion please
consider inviting my friend
pedro delfino to the compound he skates
for
death wish it would leave me speechless
i see where now he put speed um i'm not
uh maybe i'm not familiar with pedro
delfino are you saying we should have
him skate at the skate park
that would be very great we we invite a
ton of people to come out here we had um
we had this one dude do a back flip on a
scooter off of like this little bump
ramp it was crazy and he got like mad
air it was something i've never skated
in my life oh yes
yeah do you rollerblade back in the day
with me i have never
had healies illegal the closest we get
you know what helies are
they were like such a craze like the
early 2000's it's literally like a
sneaker with like a
a big fat wheel in the back of the shoe
and you just
skate around your heels you've never
seen anything
you'll see a kid like just like gliding
on his shoes
all right surprise mechanic says air
force vet here one of my flight
instructors
instructors flew hillary when she was
secretary of state she walked on the
flight deck right after he ripped the
nasty fart
she was disgusted and slammed the door
okay
beautiful j-mac says some guy is
complaining about me giving you guys
super chats even though i explained why
i do
poor guy doesn't know i also give you
guys money directly oh well keep up the
good work
please please people keep telling our
friends and fans not to donate to us so
they donate more
yes it's the greatest advertising
campaign hey you should give the money
well i'll give them more money oh no
all right let's see we got josh martinez
said this may be my last super chat
they're going
door to door and confiscating our legos
we have formed a militia and we will
resist
you know why they have to confiscate the
legos see back in the day
i mentioned the ninjas remember the
ninjas would be
like they would assassinate a feudal
lord and as they're running
they would have these japanese caltrops
but they would
serrate the the the metal so they could
dip poison in it and
and the grooves would hold poison and so
when you stepped on it not only did you
get spiked by the cow trout but you got
poisoned
well today's day and age we have more
advanced weaponry and technology
so now when the ninjas are running they
need to only throw legos on the ground
yeah and then everyone's stepping on the
legos legos
not even poison just legos just stepping
on the legos
even through the shoe it's like one
guy's got like a giant lego just through
his foot and he's like help me and
they're like i can't
and that's why they're like we better
confiscate these legos yeah it's true
that
makes more sense than the real reason
yeah the ultimate cow trough
that would be a funny sketch as well
like like they're just legos but like
they're in the foot like and there's
like lego sticking out
all over like they went through his
flesh and he's like oh
lego cal traps man yeah
all right let's see where we're at dano
says
breaking news imperial forces found a
lego death star set on tatooine
in the former home of luke skywalker
emperor palpatine outraged
trooted on a shop at a pressure dark
side there you go beautiful
all right phoenix ammunition says olivia
better remember to bring her
singlet to the solutionary summit we've
got business to handle
what is that yeah oh you guys are you
guys familiar with maj toure black
oh yeah of course yeah he throws this
annual solutionary summit i was a
speaker last year this year it's in
miami and i told a bunch of people at
twitter beef with that i will wrestle
them if they see me
irl at the solutionary summit nice
wrestling yeah a good uh a good
uh fair match with a nice referee to to
prove
yeah yeah you know that's why that's how
i settle to a beef yeah that's a good
way to settle
yeah it's the right way to do it
gentlemanly
mutual sporting combat all right let's
see we got here
pin global news says hey tim and crew
listen to you guys every day at work i
recently started a news commentary
channel intertwined with some gaming
how about makes news a little more easy
and fun to watch pin global
right on man uh-oh brett russell says
second night in a row tim mentions
ninjas
check out steven hayes versus swat team
they were sneaky and patient
farmers and shop owners not hollywood
cool stuff
all right keeping america afloat says if
government is supposed to protect our
rights
and the big tech companies violate them
wouldn't the government contracting
the big tech be treason not treason
obviously you'd like to be like hey
that's wrong you can't do that
but it's actually just more like they're
outsourcing violations of the
constitution because
the government i don't think the
government is supposed to protect our i
mean well maybe they're supposed to
protect our rights but in a perfect
world
yeah right exactly yeah government
doesn't do that all that much so i don't
know what else to say
stonehenge says will we get alex jones
part two in the future
technically we already did the first
yeah the first alex jones thing we did
got pulled down
so we immediately so that's the story
right youtube took down our alex jones
michael mal's episode
and then people were like go to you know
they do they're censoring you and people
are like tim's so
lame like he he's totally letting
youtube walk all over them like the
first thing i did after the episode got
taken down was i texted michael and alex
i was like guys can you come back on
because we got to do it again
we're going to do it again and i posted
the goofy meme i'll do it again
but they couldn't come right away so
like we did it a week later we should
have alex back when we have the new
studio yeah
have like a group of people that'd be
really fun yeah we i want to get alex
if he's willing to come on with someone
and like i was thinking it'd be really
interesting to have people who are in
political
politics and culture but not in the same
areas have conversations
so like you know we had michael and alex
and they're in a similar space
you know it's a it's culture war it's
politics it'd be interesting to have
someone who's focuses on like economics
or peter schiff maybe i don't know if
he'd want to sit down with alex jones i
would love to see chank jugger and alex
no way oh i could not that would result
in a fight yeah that's not gonna
if it didn't that would be the glimmer
of humanity i was there that i need
i was there uh when they were fighting i
think that's the dnc
when alex showed up and then he went to
the set of the young turks because it
was like
the young turks were doing a show but it
was an open area in the press area you
just like walked past him and then alex
shut up and he's filming and he's
laughing and then
i think jimmy dore was jimmy's spanish
yeah
yeah i was there i was crazy oh you were
yeah i was there i was
we were chilling yeah yep yep yep
um i don't know if we we do have
uh should we mention the plan for august
if you want yeah it's all confirmed and
locked in though no it's not
so no i don't mention it it's not no
it's not i'm waiting for them
for who okay so we have some guests that
are going to come in august i hope but i
need to hear back from them like details
of like for
booking flights and stuff but they both
agreed they did yeah that's true
it's gonna be like uh we're gonna do
posters for it yeah
and it's gonna be probably stupid to
over hype
but you know it's gonna be a right the
left and we're gonna come in and it's
gonna be like uh
a gentlemanly debate
posters all indeed so we won't say
anything just yet but not yet yeah but
we'll uh we'll we'll announce it once we
have everything
you know locked in i believe we have a
confirmation a yes
but we need to have like flights and
hotels and everything yeah i want
receipts
yeah exactly all right let's see rhett
bletcher says hi guys i'm a 25 year old
farmer in nebraska
i raise my own livestock and food
kamala's comment on rural americans is
truly a stab in our backs
every time i go to vote i have to show
my id or else i cannot participate
why do people talk down the rural people
so sad
because city people they are the
well-to-do
good moral upstanding citizens who want
to help the poor marginalized who don't
know anything about them
imagine that you know it's like when
someone comes here and says would you
like to donate to help the poor children
and you give them 20 bucks they go thank
you so much and they go buy a
cheeseburger with it
so these people in these cities are like
i'm helping these poor poor rural people
nothing you do is helping them i don't
think the people in the cities actually
want to help the rural people they'll
help the poor people in the city but
you know when when texas was having
these like
mass uh power outages there were plenty
of
liberal city elitist saying oh well
they've with a republican
you know they're all these these
backwoods hicks they vote a republican
they deserve it
they get what's coming for them like
they don't really care yeah
i don't know but if if there's cont if
city people are feeling contempt for
country people
i think it's because they think the city
people think the country people are
cowards
because they're not facing other humans
no i think that city people look down on
country people because they think
they're unsophisticated yeah
i think they like their degrees right
yeah that kind of stuff but who provides
your food
you know who provides your energy yeah
they don't think about that though
zach says if tim thinks living in a
broken nation will be fine because he
has chickens he's obviously never lived
in a destabilized country before
americans have it so good and it shows
when they say asinine comments like this
or how about sats you greatly
underestimate my experience in many
parts of the world i've been to
venezuela i've been in egypt morocco
ukraine i've been to brazil i've been to
the slums
i've been to the favelas yeah let me
just put it in very simple terms
i didn't say life will be better i said
actually we'll lose a lot of our luxury
but i'll tell you this
i will be fine i know i will i know
most conservatives in rural areas
probably will be fine
a large portion of them probably will
not be fine city people will be
absolutely screwed
but i'll put it very very simply if if
the country destabilizes
my life will go from fantastic luxury
to gutter trash but guess what i've been
gutter trash
i've been homeless i'm not scared of
being in the middle of the woods and
having to figure things out and
surviving
that's just the real world everything
else is just borrowed
luxury it's amazing to me how americans
just live in the absolute
of absolute luxury and you still have
these occupy protests complaining
you still have people demanding the
government give them more stuff and they
barely work as it is
i've watched i've seen i've seen people
who have no teeth and they're in their
20s because they mine sulfur and other
garbage like that
i've been in countries where people live
in
in hollowed-out destroyed buildings
i mean i've i've actually been to a
bunch of gutter squats in the united
states and i've seen how people live
when they have nothing
and i've been to venezuela and we got to
drive past where
the tower of david i think they call it
where the they tried building a
skyscraper and
it failed and the company shut down and
now it's just people walking up 100
flights of stairs
bro i've seen what destabilized
countries look like
and when you live in the middle of
nowhere and you can handle yourself
and you're confident in yourself and
you've prepared and you have research
and you have resources
i'm not going to pretend like i'm bear
grylls and i know how to you know i
could fight a grizzly bear with my bare
hands
but i can tell you this i am resourceful
and capable and i'm not worried
will it suck yes of course it will i
like skateboarding
i like going to the movies all that goes
away but you know what
i'm a survivor a lot of other people are
and i'll tell you
who is going to truly regret it it's the
city people not the country people
there's like there's some dude in a
mountain right now who's like just
super ripped and like chopping lumber
and he's like why do i care about those
people
taking care of themselves chop in the
wood because you need the wood for the
stove you got to cook your food going
out hunting
you know what man i'm not going to
pretend to have half the skill of those
people but i do know that i'm
resourceful enough to survive in in
absolute chaos
all right bcdevil says if the united
states was to fracture into city-states
or smaller countries
what does this stop other foreign
nations take advantage of the divisions
and see an easy acquisition of new
territory in the states
which is exactly why we said east coast
goes to europe midwest and northern
states go to canada
southern states go to mexico and the
west coast goes to china
yep that was the john teter thing i
think though so
it is what it is you know all right
let's see we got let's see i just saw
something and i
man of culture says speaking of
comparisons to the roman empire
there was a period where they waged
offensive wars in the name of security
and defense of the empire
sounds like the neocon bush doctrine
yeah i was like 400 bc to 600 a.d
basically that the entire history of
that country was
aggressive war in the name of defense
because in the very beginning they were
rome was conquered and destroyed and 90
of the people were massacred so like
they had this old consciousness of like
we have to fight we have to kill our
enemies before they destroy us
it wasn't really it was like 300 bc to
580 or something
all right let's see charles dixon says
remember the bonham richard
the first warship brought down in
american waters by communist
infiltration
brutal pete conrad jr says as a former
usmc sergeant
i say whoever was in command of a usn
surrender to iranians
should be njp'd and sent to the brig p.s
this is algernon
will you help me find my daughter
madison she watches her show but i don't
know how i can get her my phone number
uh i don't know either but perhaps
shouting it out will be
enough we'll see i suppose
all right let's see did i read this one
already okay i did read this one already
don't wanna double up let's see what we
got here
gohan v says hour of the times thank you
for the super chat
christopher says make sure luke knows i
saw a squirrel once
you guys should send luke all of your
love and you can tweet at him and say
luke we love you and follow luke we are
change on twitter
and let him know that no luke we puke
every night before the show we all sit
here and
recognize that luke isn't here and then
we all just vomit profusely and
then we gotta clean it up and it's all
over the table it gets on the keyboard
it's like the 12th keyboard we've gone
through because we just keep barfing
because luke's not here yeah it's true
also i think it's funny that people are
like saying no luke i puke when like
luke and puke don't rhyme
yeah but then someone said no luke i
duke and i'm like all right well that
actually rhymes
better yes i don't want that no let's
not do that
gloom flower says i would love to buy an
anti-crap
t-shirt it would be so awesome that's
actually a good idea
love it critical race applied principles
we are anti-crap
i don't know maybe that's a little too
silly i like it
abele says the woke ideology in the
military is going to lead to world war
three
our enemies will see it as an
opportunity to attack if we don't stop
destroying ourselves from within
it will spell war on america's shores
this needs to change
now yeah you know i agree but
unfortunately
it's a it's a it's a rot you know the
rot has gotten to the core
and now the foundations are falling down
this is the the thing about similar to
the romans is if
still in the blank then we will be
attacked if something something then we
will be attacked so it's
always like we're on the offense to
prevent being attacked we've created the
military-industrial complex to prevent
being attacked
because hitler attacked um he attacked
us and the romans were always afraid of
being attacked and now we are too
it seems like maybe that's justifiable
maybe it's like there is no homeostasis
either you're the aggressor or the
aggressed
all right i would love a homeostasis on
this planet dana ness says
re ian's app idea what if instead of
voting from the app you put in your zip
and get a list of proposed bills by city
state federal
along with info on who wrote and
sponsors the bill and contact
information for representatives
at each level i like that better
fantastic but that's still
the problem there is still that a lot of
people
who vote don't know or don't care that's
a good point
they're like i'm going to put a mark on
the d i'm going to put a mark on an r
and then they walk out
and the easier you make it the easier it
is to do that oh that's right
yup what is that people are saying luke
is in the chat is he he is yeah
oh he is yeah luke everybody's puking
what are you doing
where are you at atlas
talk i bet you just went like atlas
so so luke was supposed to be gone for
only a few weeks what happened
we're still waiting lucas g mato says
max kaiser and alex jones has that ever
happened before
cool cool energy has that ever happened
before no i think so
that has to have happened before they're
both such energetic individuals
so nice to put it mildly that would be
that would be
that would be a lot of fun max is a
bitcoin guy so he's not overly into
a lot of the other political spaces yeah
maybe interesting conversation too
yeah that yeah yeah all right
let's maybe maybe we'll do that that's a
thought
lord beerus says ever consider tom
mcdonald for your show might be fun
well yeah absolutely so absolutely
mom has a standing invite uh but i don't
know if you've noticed at the rate he's
dropping music that man is unbelievably
busy and he's doing it all on his own
with his girlfriend and his pal
so whenever he gets a break we'd love to
have him
right jerome morrow says please create a
fictional episodic show that starts as
very thinly veiled narrative of the
current activity of the american
authoritarian left
and then proceeds to depict the horrific
nightmare dystopia that inevitably
follows
yeah we could you know the thing is like
cgi is is getting relatively cheap
these days and you can do a lot with
just one room that's all green
oh yeah so we could theoretically make a
whole show
a fictional sci-fi in filmed in one room
isn't that crazy yeah you just get one
room and make the whole thing green and
light it
and light it up properly i suppose you
know you have to
move the lighting for every you know
every angle you're doing when you're
filming but it's totally possible to do
that
yeah that'd be that'd be pretty epic all
right let's see
we'll just do uh we'll do one more right
here amenthy says how much
in super chats to get ian in the rainbow
monkey costume for a halloween show
i would do that for free oh wow no no no
no
no
we are going to do we're going to do so
as part of the new website we're
actually going to have
like a a an auction functionality
because what we're going to do for the
the live events which hopefully we will
have
in the next like month or so announce
one of our first events they were
supposed to be months and months ago
we're a bit you know jammed up in the
process the way it's going to work is
there's going to be
first come first serve as well as
highest bidder
we're trying to find a way to make it as
maximally
open as possible some people were like i
work 24 7. how am i supposed to be able
to go on the internet and buy a ticket
before anyone else if i'm at work and
i'm like
so then maybe what we do is people can
bid on tickets
and we can also make it so that people
can buy tickets if it's first come first
serve
that way there's an option for people
who are at work and don't have time but
can spend a little bit more money and
then people who don't have that much
money but might have more time
i just trying to figure out how to make
it work but we can do an auction on
variety of costumes like you know make
ian wear the rainbow
oh no yeah i like doing it with my own
free will
but if you want to entice we can have
people buy costumes or something
or we can you know we'll do we'll do a
poll we'll like have people
vote we'll have people submit costume
ideas dudes
send me clothes and i will wear them
send me crazy outfits
to the p.o box and i'll wear them uh
that's actually a good idea
yeah so at timcast.com and i think it's
in the context section there's a po box
ian said it right there send ian your
clothes you're gonna get a bunch of
banned t-shirts that'd be fine
i mean i need more clothes anyway more
crazy shirts are saying that yeah it's
true
all right everybody haven't already give
that like button a little tap subscribe
to this channel share the show with your
friends go to timcast.com
become a member at around 11 or so we
will have a members only podcast up
from uh which is the extension of
tonight's show that's where we talk
about the things that youtube tells us
we can't really talk about
so like whatever ian's costume might end
up being we'll say the actual name of it
because we can't say it for the most
part on youtube
you can follow this show on instagram
and facebook at tim cast irl
we're also on tik tok at tim cast
underscore irl we're just trying to
leverage these networks to get people to
go to the website because ultimately we
want to have our own independent media
platform that is
that doesn't need any of these social
networks for the time being though we
don't want to see that ground in the
culture
by just abandoning them so it's a
double-edged sword i guess it's it's
it's
it's hard to know how to deal with this
stuff because these the censorship is
really really awful
you can follow me personally at tim cast
and again make sure you subscribe hit
that like button
olivia do you want to mention your
social media or oh yeah subscribe to my
youtube olivia rondo r-o-n-d-e-a-u on
twitter at rondolivia on instagram
rondo.olivia you can also follow me in
crossland.net and
ian crossland on social media thanks for
coming you guys may follow me
at sourpatchlids as i attempt to gain
more followers on twitter than sourpatch
kids
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com for that members only
podcast
thanks for hanging out bye guys
you